Der Hasenfroh.
Liebe HSV-Fans, ich verspreche zur nächsten Zweitligaligatour werde ich ein anderes Intro gemacht haben. Ich habe es jetzt zeitlich nicht geschafft. Ich hatte das halt noch von der letzten Sendung darliegen. Wenn ihr andere Ideen habt, was man für so eine Zweitligasendung als O-Ton nehmen könnte, dann schickt sie mir bitte. Irgendwas über Willy Landgraf oder ich weiß es ja nicht. Aber deswegen muss ich nochmal –es tut mir leid, dass ich nochmal in diese offene Wunde reinpieksen musste. Es war das letzte Mal schon auf Kante genäht. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen im Rasenfunk. Schön, dass ihr da seid und schön, dass ihr zuhört. Vielleicht sogar, wenn euch dieses Intro ein bisschen wehgetan hat. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetz auf mastodon.social und auf Blue Sky. Und wir wollen jetzt eben sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Und wie immer haben wir da drei Vereine, die wir heute besprechen wollen. Einmal der FC St. Pauli. Das ist ein Teil, den hört ihr am Ende der Sendung. Das habe ich schon aufgezeichnet, mit Tim Eckstein vom Millan-Ton. Und jetzt hier bei mir begrüße ich einmal Anna Niemens von Früff unter anderem. Und ihr kennt sie auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk Royal. Da haben wir den Abstieg verarbeitet. Und wer hätte gedacht, Anna, dass wir so schnell widersprechen müssen? Schön, dass du hier bist. Das ist nie ein gutes Zeichen, ehrlich gesagt, für die Absteiger, wenn die früh wieder drankommen in der Ligatur, dann ist was passiert. Aber es hat Hertha auch schon erwischt, also sei getrost. Eigentlich hätten wir die Runde mit Marc noch mal machen können im Nachhinein, wenn ich das gewusst hätte. Naja, aber schön, dass du wieder da bist. Ja, sehr, sehr gerne. Und dann feiert sein Debüt hier Jörg Ruffert. Er ist FC Magdeburg-Fan. Er hat unter anderem dafür gesorgt, dass ich Magdeburg eine Lesung hatte. Herzlichen Dank dafür. War jetzt aber nicht die Bedingung, hier in die Sendung zu kommen. So läuft es noch nicht. Wobei, wenn ich so drüber nachdenke, könnte ich das eigentlich mal einführen. Also Jörg, schön, dass du hier bist.
Danke, dass ich dabei sein darf.
Ja, wie schön, dass du da bist. Also wir hatten quasi über Twitter schon ein bisschen Kontakt und hast gesagt, komm doch mal nach Magdeburg. Und ich dachte mir, Mensch, über Magdeburg wollte ich doch auch mal so ein bisschen die Fanperspektive abbilden, weil ich zuletzt oft mit Journalisten über Magdeburg gesprochen habe. Und da bin ich bei dir an der richtigen Adresse, oder? Sehr gut. Die Antworten, sie müssen noch ein bisschen ausführlicher werden, aber das kriegen wir locker hin. Wir sind jetzt am 8. Spieltag dieser 2. Liga. St. Pauli ist Tabellenführer, HSV und Hannover direkt dahinter. Über St. Pauli sprechen wir ja am Ende dieser Sendung noch ausführlicher. Aber Anna, jetzt ist es ja für dich quasi wieder ein erstes Jahr 2. Liga. Was ist denn bisher so für ein Jahr für dich? Gibt es Teams, die dich überrascht haben, irgendwelche Sachen, die in jüngerer Vergangenheit passiert sind, die jetzt erstmal nicht mit Schalke zu tun haben, die du irgendwie erwähnenswert findest?
Also, ich finde die Liga unglaublich spannend. Ein bisschen dynamischer als die Bundesliga, weil es jede Woche gibt es so Überraschungen, die man gar nicht auf dem Schirm hat. Jeder kann jeden schlagen so ein bisschen in der 2. Liga. Ich bin sehr von Hannover überrascht, weil das Hannover, was sich diese Saison zeigt, oder jetzt die letzten Spieltage gezeigt hat, ist ein ganz anderes Hannover als das Hannover aus der letzten Saison. Die haben sich ja kaum verändert im Kader, außer so jemanden wie Halzenberg, der dazugekommen ist. Deswegen bin ich sehr überrascht, dass die da oben stehen. Aber die spielen durchaus ansehnlichen Fußball und haben es auch verdient.
Ich glaube, Hannover kann auch nicht glauben, wie gut Hannover aktuell ist. Aber das werden wir, glaube ich, auch nochmal bald hier in der Ligatur besprechen müssen. Jörg, wie ist so dein Eindruck von der aktuellen Saison? Wie gefällt es dir bisher?
Wir sind ziemlich gut gestartet, obwohl wir dachten, nach dem ersten Spieltag das 1-1 gegen Wiesbaden, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig. Das hat sich aber im Laufe der ersten Spieltage gezeigt, dass das ein recht gutes Ergebnis war. Dann haben wir kontinuierlich gepunktet bis zum fünften Spieltag, bis zu diesem legendären 6-4 gegen Hertha, was eigentlich kaum noch in Dramatik zu überbieten war. Ja gut, der Spieltag davor auf Pauli, das 0-0, da weiß ich eigentlich selber nicht, wie wir zu diesem Punkt gekommen sind, weil ich glaube, es gab 30 zu zwei Torschüsse oder so, aber Pauli war an dem Tag einfach nicht in der Lage, ins Tor zu treffen bzw. mal ein Torwart angeschossen. Fürs zweite Jahr, zweite Liga bin ich natürlich super zufrieden mit dem offensiven Platz, also ist alles gut. Die letzten drei Spiele waren jetzt vielleicht nicht so toll, aber ich glaube, die Mannschaft weiß schon, was geht und dass sie eigentlich auch recht gut sind. Also ich denke, da geht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist gut zu hören. Und wie ist das jetzt dann im zweiten Jahr? Guckt man da dann besonders auf die Aufsteiger? Elvesberg, Wiesbaden, Osnabrück stehen ja jetzt stand jetzt alle hinter Magdeburg. Ist das so was, was du dann genau im Blick hast, weil du halt hoffst, hoffentlich landen die auch hinter uns, dann bleiben wir drin?
Ja, letztlich ist es irgendwie so natürlich klar. Und man denkt, okay, da kommt ja jemand aus der dritten Liga. Wir haben ja gerade in der zweiten Hälfte der ersten Saison, zweite Liga, haben wir eigentlich eine sehr solide Runde gespielt und waren auch spielerisch wirklich stark, sodass man irgendwie gedacht hat, ja, die sollten wir schon im Griff haben. Aber ja, erster Spieltag hat halt gezeigt, Wiesbaden ist eben doch nicht so einfach, es sind auch andere gestolpert dort. Aber letztlich geht es irgendwo darum, das zweite Jahr gut zu überstehen. Aber ich denke, es wird für uns keine Zitterpartie diesmal.
Was mich interessieren würde, bevor wir nochmal auf eure Vereine näher gucken, wie ihr den Unterschied der zweiten Liga zur einmal ersten Liga, Anna, und einmal dann zur dritten Liga, wenn sie jetzt natürlich auch schon zwei Jahre zurückliegt, bewertet. Anna, du hast schon gesagt, dass es quasi ein bisschen offener ist, jeder kann jeden schlagen. Wie findest du es so vom Niveau der Spiele her und so weiter?
Im Vergleich zur Bundesliga? Ich finde, ich weiß gar nicht, ich finde eigentlich, es hat schon ein ähnliches Niveau wie in der Bundesliga. Also einige Mannschaften, würde ich jetzt sagen. Ich sehe da nicht so einen krassen Unterschied. Aber man merkt schon, dass man in jedem Spiel an sein Limit gehen muss. Oder die Mannschaft muss in jedem Spiel ans Limit gehen, muss über die 100 Prozent hinausgehen. Das war in der Bundesliga manchmal nicht so, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Und Jörg, wie ist der Unterschied zwischen dritter Liga und zweiter Liga?
Na, der ist doch schon deutlich, finde ich. Also wir sind natürlich nach dem ersten Halbjahr dann recht gut angekommen und haben das ziemlich souverän am Ende geschafft. Spielerisch und gerade körperlich ist das ein enormer Unterschied. Ich finde aber die zweite Liga alles in allem von den Namen der Vereine, die da sind, weit interessanter als inzwischen die Bundesliga.
Das glaube ich dir. Seit wann bist du Fußballfan, Jörg?
Ja, Fußballfan seit ich selber Fußballspieler bin. Seit sechs Jahren, seit ich sechs war sozusagen. Vielleicht mit zehn, elf bin ich dann zum FCM gekommen über das Idol meiner Jugend, Joachim Streich. Als Berliner habe ich das natürlich immer nur mit aus der Entfernung verfolgt und habe irgendwie gehofft, der FCM gerade nach der Rende würde dann halt mal den Sprung schaffen, weil der Anspruch Magdeburger Größenbahner ist halt irgendwie ein bisschen anders. Und als Europapokalsieger und dann auch noch als Alleiniger der DDR tut man natürlich schon so, als gehört man da auch hin. Letztlich so sieht sich die Stadt und Magdeburg ist eine Sportstadt. Man denkt an den SC Magdeburg oder an den Olympiastützpunkt. Ich glaube, da ist großes Potenzial.
Handball ja auch, also Magdeburg wirklich mit vielen Disziplinen dabei. Dann lass doch mal direkt über den FCM sprechen. Also du hast ja schon so ein bisschen den Zwischenstand angedeutet. Man hat jetzt 12 Punkte, 3 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen, 17 zu 14 Tore. Also 31 Tore in den 8 Spielen mit FCM-Beteiligung. Das ist vielleicht nicht so untypisch für eine Christian-Titz-Mannschaft, aber besonders mit dem 10-Tore-Spiel gegen Hertha haben wir das halt. Ich glaube, auch national hat das jeder wahrgenommen, dass da viel los ist bei Magdeburg. Du hast schon gesagt, dass du eigentlich zufrieden bist mit dem Start in die Saison. Ehrlich gesagt, alles andere hätte mich auch verwundert bei dem Zwischenstand. Hat sich denn noch mal was verändert zwischen der letzten Saison und dieser Saison?
Na ja, die Mannschaft ist im Großen und Ganzen zusammengeblieben. Es gab zwei, drei Verstärkungen. Wir hatten auch einen schmerzlichen Abgang zum Vorfall Bochum. Der Jean-Hugo Ney, der dazugekommen ist, hat uns viel Stabilität gebracht. Er ist, glaube ich, seit drei Spieltagen verletzt. Aber im Wesentlichen, vom Spielstil her, von der Zusammensetzung der Mannschaft, von den Spielern, die auf dem Platz stehen, hat es höchstens ein, zwei Verinnerungen gegeben. Ich glaube, das ist grundsätzlich auch nicht verkehrt, wenn man die Truppe so zusammenhält oder so wachsen lässt. Und offensichtlich scheint ja das auch an anderen Stellen zu funktionieren, wenn man jetzt an Hannover denkt.
Und der schmerzliche Abgang ist Moritz Bruni-Quarteng zum VfL gewechselt. Da wird er jetzt vielleicht auch mal endlich im Kader stehen, weil das war bisher so ein bisschen der schlechte Witz auf Bochum, dass eben der teuerste Einkauf, glaube ich, sogar dieses Sommers bisher da noch gar nicht zum Einsatz gekommen ist. Guckst du da manchmal noch hin und was fehlt mit Quarteng, dem FCM?
Also wirklich hingucken, tatsächlich nicht. Aber er hat so Moves, Bewegungen drauf gehabt, die waren für viele Gegenspieler einfach unberechenbar. Und dadurch hat er sich oft Raum verschafft und Situationen kreiert und eben auch Tore geschossen, die wirklich dann auch besonders waren und uns auch geholfen haben. Das war aber auch nötig, weil Lukas Schuhler, den wir ja schon seit anderthalb Jahren bei uns haben, seit er Langzeitverletzt war und deswegen nicht spielen konnte. Der junge Mann hat ja nun seit Anfang dieser Saison doch gut getroffen. Ich glaube, die letzten drei Spiele jetzt nicht, aber ansonsten hat er immer das 1 zu 0 geschossen, auch im Pokal. Und ja, das ist schon ganz gut da.
Also ist Schuler jetzt dann quasi der Ersatz für den Spieler, der mal der Ersatz für Schuler sein sollte?
So direkt kann man es, glaube ich, auch nicht sagen. Er war ja eingeplant, hatte sich halt relativ schwer verletzt und war, glaube ich, ein Dreivierteljahr raus, hatte nur ganz wenige Spiele gemacht und ein Tor geschossen. Und er konnte also diese Entwicklung, die man sich von ihm erhofft hatte, nicht machen durch die Verletzung. Und ansonsten hat man halt viele von diesen quirligen Spielern, also Baris Atik, Tatsuya Ito, Jason Schäker, wo sozusagen immer jemand war, der auch in diese Lücke springen konnte, die der Moritz Bonik hinterlassen hat.
War denn die Vertragsverlängerung von Baris Atik so ein bisschen das Wichtigste, was passiert ist in diesem Sommer? Weil von außen, also aus emotionalen Gesichtspunkten, hatte ich das Gefühl, hat das eine große Rolle gespielt. Wenn ich mir jetzt die bisherige Bilanz angucke, er hat schon wieder sechs Vorlagen aus acht Spielen, auch fünf gelbe Karten aus acht Spielen. Also auch dazu herzlichen Glückwunsch. Aber ich hatte das Gefühl, das war was, was ja so eine Signalwirkung hatte.
Das kann man schon so sagen, ja. Also er hat wohl auch selbst gesagt, dass er in Magdeburg noch nicht fertig ist, dass er noch was erreichen will. Und vielleicht ist er auch in gewisser Weise dem Club dankbar, dass er diese Chance bekommen hat, nachdem er vertragslos war. Und auf und sich, dass er mit Christian Thies auch einen Trainer hat, der ihn anzupacken weiß und er ist immer hochgradig engagiert und haut sich voll rein mit allem, was er hat. Und leider führt das auch dazu, dass er gelegentlich zu viel meckert. Und ich glaube, drei von den fünf gelben Karten hat er schon wieder wegen meckern kassiert.
Ah, der Mario Götze der zweiten Liga.
Leider muss er das nächste Spiel auch wieder aussetzen.
Ja gut, das kommt in den besten Familien offenbar vor. Jetzt gab es ja vor gar nicht so allzu langer Zeit das direkte Duell zwischen euren Mannschaften. Deswegen kann ich da jetzt auch sehr gut Anna mal mit reinholen. Also Schalke 04 hat es ja geschafft, gegen ein dezidiertes Magdeburg zu Hause 4 zu 3 zu gewinnen. Also da sind natürlich auch 7 Tore gefallen. Ihr beide wart im Stadion. Anna, erzähl erst mal du deine Sicht auf dieses Spiel. Und dann darf Jörg mal gerne gegenschneiden mit seiner Perspektive.
Also nach der ersten 25 Minuten hatte ich natürlich nicht gedacht, dass Schalke dieses Spiel noch dreht.
Da stand es 0 zu 2.
Genau, so ehrlich muss ich auch sein. Das war auch keine gute Leistung. Mal wieder von Schalke. Und dann, was dann passiert ist, weiß ich auch nicht. Also das war völlig verrückt. Das hat anscheinend so einen Klick gemacht bei der Mannschaft in den Köpfen. Ja, dann lief es einfach. Und ich war völlig fertig nach dem Spiel. Das war wirklich eins der emotionalsten Spiele, die ich in letzter Zeit live erlebt habe mit Schalke.
Also es war eben 0 zu 2 nach 27 Minuten. Dann Ausgleich, 40. und 62. der Ausgleich. Dann der erneute Rückstand, 67. Da dachte man sich schon, mein Gott, Schalke, gibt dir das wieder her. Aber nein, 69. Minute, 3 zu 3. Dann rote Karte und Strafstoß zum 4 zu 3. Und wenn ich mich aber richtig erinnere, Jörg, im Spielbericht war quasi jetzt das Spiel fertig, aber in der Schlussphase ist schon auch noch einiges passiert. Das ist bei mir jetzt auch schon wieder weit hinten Richtung Wirbelsäule. Aber es war schon bis zuletzt ein spannendes Ding.
Ich sage mal, es gab buchstäblich in letzter Minute noch eine Kopfballchance, die der Schalker Torwart herausragend geklärt hat. Er hat da irgendwie unten vom Pfosten weggekratzt, sonst wäre da der Ausgleich noch gefallen. Aber ja, wir müssen uns ja einfach den Vorwurf machen, dass wir viel zu schlampig mit manchen Dingen umgegangen sind. Das 2-1 war geschenkt, weil wir wieder zehnmal vom Strafraum quer spielen und das spielerisch lösen wollten, anstatt den Ball mal langzuschlagen. Dann kam halt ein Pass zu kurz und dann wurde der Tauwart in unnötige Bedrängnis gebracht. So viel das Gegentor. Das ist leider nicht das erste Mal in dieser Saison, das ist schon öfter vorgekommen. Deswegen haben wir auch 14 Gegentore, weil wir immer wieder in gewissen Situationen viel zu leichtwertig hinten agieren.
Aber muss das so sein, wenn man Christian Tietz als Trainer hat? Also man weiß ja, er will einen offensiven Fußball spielen lassen, der Torhüter wird da sehr in den Spielaufbau eingebunden. Ist aber auch schön anzusehen. Also relativ viel wird über Passspiel aufgelöst. Aber man ist auch relativ mit vielen Spielern in der gegnerischen Hälfte und deswegen dann eben anfälliger für Konto und so weiter. Gab es schon mal eine Phase, wo das besser war bei Magdeburg? Oder ist das einfach so, what you see is what you get? Das ist halt einfach Christian Titz. Und dann muss man das halt einfach aushalten und das eigene Herz muss das mitmachen.
Naja, das ist schon so gewollt, diese Art von Fußball. Und gelegentlich geht es halt schief. Und wenn ein Gegner besonders gut presst und früh anläuft, dann eher mal, als wenn er das eben nicht tut. Und ja, vielleicht hängt es auch mal damit zusammen, wenn ein Spieler verletzt ist und die gewohnte Ordnung dann hinten nicht da ist. Oder wenn du jemanden durch eine gelbe Karte mal ersetzen musst, dass das dann eben so kommt. Aber es gehört zum Fußball dazu. Also im Moment kann man sagen, wo Magdeburg ist, ist eigentlich immer viel Spektakel. Bei uns im Stadion ist es sehr laut. Ich glaube, wir sind auch auswärts ziemlich laut. Anna wird es bestimmt bestätigen können. Ja. Es war auch sehr brachial auf Schalke. Und das war sehr cool. Und irgendwann war die Schalke über Macht zu groß. Kurzverschluss, da waren wir nicht mehr zu hören. Und wir konnten auch nicht mehr, weil es so heiß war im Stadion. Es war unglaublich an dem Tag.
Ich sehe schon, ihr seid beide noch geflecht von diesem Spiel. Ich bin ein bisschen neidisch, dass ihr es erlebt habt. Denn das war, glaube ich, wirklich etwas Besonderes. Aber erzähl mir mal ein bisschen was von Magdeburg, Jörg. Weil wir haben über Tits und so weiter, haben wir ja auch schon letzte Saison gesprochen. Und viele kennen die gute Atmosphäre beim FCM. Manche wissen dann auch noch, da gibt es eben Erfolge in der Vergangenheit. Jetzt eben gerade das große Jubiläum. 1974 hat man einfach den Europapokal, der Pokalsieger gewonnen. Da wird eben jetzt das Jubiläum begangen. Komischerweise durfte da auch ich lesen. Aber ihr seid sehr fremdenfreundlich, würde ich an der Stelle sagen. Aber was ist denn Magdeburg für einen Fußballstandort? Du hast schon gesagt, Sportstadt. Aber mir scheint, und mir schien es jetzt auch in der ganz kurzen Zeit, in der ich jetzt in Magdeburg war in dieser Woche, also der Fußball hat da aber schon nochmal eine besondere Rolle.
Ja, das kann man wirklich so sagen. Also, man müsste wahrscheinlich noch viel weiter ausholen, als ich es jetzt kann mit meiner räumlichen Entfernung von Berlin aus. Ich bin ja kein echter Magdeburger. Und die Besonderheit von 1974 war halt, alle Spieler kamen aus der Region. Es gab ja dazu, in der DDR-Zeiten gab es so Bezirke, da gab es halt einen Bezirk Magdeburg. Und alle Spieler, die da waren, die waren halt ein eingeschwornener Haufen und die waren wirklich innerhalb weniger Kilometer zu Hause. Unter Heinz Krüge damals hat der FCM lange Zeit eine sehr erfolgreiche Zeit gehabt. Da waren dann, ich glaube, drei Meister-Titel, der Europapokalsieg. Da gab es dann auch die Duellen gegen die Bayern. Ich glaube, das Supercup-Spiel fand dann aus irgendeinem Grund nicht statt.
Ja, der DDR-Verband wollte das damals nicht. Da habe ich mich noch mal eingelesen vor der Lesung. Die Bayern hatten richtig Bock, weil die hätten 1,2 Millionen D-Mark damit. Und überall, wo sie Geld verdienen konnten, fand die Bayern damals schon klasse. Magdeburg wollte es angeblich auch, aber musste dann zurückziehen. Sehr wahrscheinlich war es aber der DDR-Fußballverband, der diesen direkten Vergleich nicht haben wollte. Im Jahr vorher war es erst mal so, dass der Ostmeister gegen den Westmeister gespielt hat. Mit Dresden gegen Bayern damals. Enge Spiele, aber Bayern hat es gewonnen. Dann bei der WM BRD gegen DDR haben auch alle mitbekommen. Da hat Sparwasser dann das 1 zu 0 gemacht. Aus verschiedenen Gründen wollte das wahrscheinlich sogar die Stasi direkt selber nicht. So kam dann dieses Supercup-Spiel nicht zustande. Aber das hat sich dann erledigt, als man in der zweiten Runde zueinander gelost wurde im Europapokal der Landesmeister. Und das war quasi die große Phase von Magdeburg?
Das war die große Phase. Genau, das ging dann auch noch einige Jahre weiter, bis Anfang der 80er. Da habe ich dann auch das erste Mal meinen, oder den ersten Pokalsieg für mich live miterlebt. Die Pokalfinals waren ja damals in Berlin, im Stadion der Weltjugend. Und da weiß ich noch, bin ich als 8-Jähriger, ich meine, das war 78er im Stadion gewesen. Und wir haben damals 4-0 gewonnen. Das war für mich ein schneidendes Erlebnis. Ja, und die Hochphase ging so bis Mitte der 80er. Ich glaube, so bis 83. Und dann hat man noch so ein bisschen den Fahnen verloren. Hat dann hinter dem Stasi-gepünten Club BFC Dynamo, hinter Dynamo Dresden und auch Lokmotiv Leipzig so ein bisschen den Anschluss verloren. Karls-Heinz Jenner hat auch eine sehr gute Phase gehabt, wo man immer so auf Platz 5, 6 rumgedümpelt ist. Und das zog sich dann so bis zur Wende.
Also wir müssen da jetzt nur so tief einsteigen, wie du es möchtest. Ich hatte das jetzt gar nicht geplant, so einen historischen Abriss zu machen. Und das ist ja aus dem Stand vielleicht auch gar nicht so einfach. Aber Magdeburg war ja einer der Vereine –also Stahl Brandenburg wurde ganz aufgelöst. Und Magdeburg war dann aber einer der Vereine. Da ging es ja bis in die Oberliga dann runter. Und dann Oberliga, Regionalliga, Oberliga, Regionalliga. Und dann irgendwann hat man es dann wieder geschafft. 2015, 2016 erst dann erst wieder in die 3. Liga. Dann war man quasi zum ersten Mal wieder im Profifußball. Bei der 3. Liga ja damals dann schon wieder professioneller Fußball war. Kannst du mir erklären, was da gefehlt hat in den Jahren vorher, dass man so hart abgestürzt ist und damit ja auch quasi die Phase im deutschen Fußball verpasst hat, in der man richtig gut Geld auch verdienen konnte?
Da gibt es andere Leute, die da viel tiefer drin stecken. Also es gab finanzielle Probleme. Man stand einmal kurz vorm, ja an Gott weiß nicht, ob das das richtige Wort ist. Also es gab wirklich richtig, richtig, genau, genau, richtig schlechte Zeiten. Viele Trainerwechsel und auch Leute, die im Präsidium oder als Präsident da waren und die nicht vernünftig gewirtschaftet haben. Und erst eigentlich mit Peter Fechner damals und dann mit der Verpflichtung von Jens Hertel, ging es dann wirklich stetig aufwärts. Damals Mario Kalnick, der Managerposition übernommen hat, war ja auch ein ehemaliger Spieler. Und die drei haben sozusagen das geschafft, ein stabiles Gefüge zusammenzubauen und das auf solide wirtschaftliche Füße zu stellen. Was dann dazu führte, dass man sich irgendwie konsolidieren konnte, in finanzieller und auch sportlicher Sicht. Und ja, dann ist irgendwann der Aufstieg in die Dritte Liga geglückt. Und ab da ging es eigentlich nur noch aufwärts.
Ja, es gab einmal noch dieses Highlight. DFB-Pokal, im Elfmeterschießen die Bayern rausgeworfen, auch zu Hause, das war noch als 2000, 2001, glaube ich. Oder irgendwie so um den Dreh rum zumindest ungefähr.
Schlechte Daten.
Magdeburg war quasi ganz lange von der nationalen Bildfläche verschwunden, außer für diejenigen, die näher hingeguckt haben. Also hochspannend. Ich bin natürlich jetzt gerade auch getriggert, weil ich gerade da war und mich eingelesen habe, aber halt auch nur so ganz grob. Aber das ist schon einfach irre, diese Geschichten der ehemaligen DDR-Oberliga-Vereine, die zum Teil auch einfach keine Chance hatten. Man kommt an dem Fakt nicht vorbei, dass 150 Spieler aus der ehemaligen DDR dann zu Westverein gewechselt sind zwischen 1990 und 1995. Und allein das wäre ja schon schlimm genug, wenn dann doch alles andere an anderen Rahmenbedingungen dazu kommen. Also sehr, sehr heftig, aber umso schöner, dass man mit Magdeburg wieder einen Vertreter in der zweiten Liga hat, der auch noch für Positiv-Flagzeilen sorgt mit seiner Spielweise. Was glaubst du denn, wo das noch hingehen kann? Ich fand, dass du vorhin schon sehr optimistisch klangst. Und das habe ich jetzt aber auch aus Magdeburg mitgenommen. Angeblich soll es so sein, drei Spiele in Folge gewonnen und schon wird vom Aufstieg geträumt. Ist es denn wirklich so? Ist Magdeburg, so sagen wir mal, leicht zu begeistern?
Na ja, Magdeburger Größen waren halt, klar wäre das eine schöne Wunschvorstellung. Und letztlich machen wir uns nichts vor. Ich glaube, jeder träumt irgendwo davon, dass wir irgendwann mal erstklassig spielen wollen, können. Ich persönlich habe ja hier in meiner Heimatstadt einen Verein, der vorgemacht hat, wie es geht, Union Berlin. Sicherlich schaut man da auch so ein bisschen drauf, weil da hat man über viele Jahre ganz kontinuierlich gearbeitet, ganz seriös gearbeitet. Und das könnte ein Musterbeispiel sein, wie es Magdeburg vielleicht auch gelingt. Klar wäre es ein Traum, aber ich glaube, wenn man realistisch ist, dann müssen wir soweit noch nicht gucken. Das hat bei der Union auch lange gedauert, bis sie die zweite Liga hinter sich gelassen haben. Wenn es irgendwann mal so käme, wenn es vielleicht so käme, bevor ich 60 bin, also noch sieben Jahre Zeitpuffer, das wäre schon ein Traum, wenn ich es noch erleben darf. Aber bis dahin haben wir ja so tolle Spiele wie auf Schalke oder in Hamburg zweimal.
Ja, das kann ich vielleicht verraten. Also wir haben eben im Vorfeld des Schalke-Spiels gesprochen und aus jeder deiner Nachrichten sprang schon diese Vorfreude auf dieses Spiel und dass du da am Start und sein kannst raus. Also das war deutlich zu merken. Und ich wünsche dir übrigens, dass du sehr viel älter wirst als 60 Jahre. Das heißt, dann wäre die Deadline noch ein bisschen, weil du sagst, ich möchte es noch erleben. Sie haben noch sieben Jahre. Also wünsche ich doch sehr, dass du noch mehr Zeit hast. Wer sind dir dafür jetzt die entscheidenden Personen? Also Christian Titz ist ja klar als Trainer. Wer ist sonst noch wichtig gerade beim FCM? Und was ist so die Taktik, die man versucht, um quasi –weil man ist ja wirtschaftlich logischerweise eine der kleinsten Fische, auch in der zweiten Liga. Das heißt, man muss ja in anderen Bereichen, Scouting, Nachwuchs, ich weiß nicht, muss man ja überperformen, um überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben, diesen Union-Berlin-Weg zu gehen, so wie es ja bei Union auch der Fall war.
Ja, also Christian Thietz ist sicherlich ein Baustein. Wir hoffen, dass er solange bei uns bleiben wird. Ein weiterer Baustein wäre Otmar Schalk, oder ist er Otmar Schalk, als sportlicher Leiter-Manager, der eine sehr gute, sehr solide Arbeit macht, der aber sicherlich irgendwann an der Altersganze stoßen wird. Oder auch bei 60 oder 70 Jahren. Nein, nein, er ist schon über 60. Und dann gibt es ehemalige Spieler, die sich einbringen inzwischen. Marius Sowislow war ja unser Aufstiegskapitän in die dritte Liga. Der hat inzwischen eine sehr wichtige Funktion beim Verein. Es könnte sein, dass er vielleicht Präsident werden wird irgendwann. Es ist glaube ich vielen schon bewusst, dass das alles nur über eine solide Arbeit geht. Über Konstanz auf den wichtigen Positionen. Und wenn es uns dann vielleicht noch gelingt, einen entsprechend großen Sponsor an Land zu ziehen, der möglicherweise demnächst bei Magdeburg baut, das könnte natürlich noch das Fehlende-Puzzle-Stück sein.
Meinst du jetzt Intel mit der Edge? Ich wollte nur kurz wissen, ob wir über das Gleiche sprechen. Und was ihr nicht sehen könnt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber die Zusehenden bei YouTube, die haben es schon gemerkt, bei jeder Erwähnung des Wortes Konstanz muss Anna lachen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da los ist, aber das werden wir gleich klären.
Aber dann eine abschließende Frage, Jörg. Du hast jetzt schon die verantwortlichen Personen genannt. Was glaubst du, ist die Strategie? Wenn ich mir jetzt zum Beispiel die Transfers angucke, da kenne ich jetzt viele Spieler nicht. Ich erkenne jetzt aber da ehrlicherweise auch kein Muster. Da kommt genauso jemand von Inter Mailand, wie jemand vom HSV kommt und von Olympique Lyon. Gut, das ist Julian Pollersbeck, der ist jetzt auch ein bisschen bekannter. Rot-Weiß-Oberhausen, Groningen, Eupen, Wiesbaden, Aalen. Also da scheint mir irgendwie so alles mit dabei zu sein. Gibt es denn irgendwas, was so einen typischen Neuzugang beim FCM ausmacht?
Also ich glaube, da möchte man schon gerne hin, dass die Spieler wirklich gut auch menschlich zueinander passen, dass sie bereitwillig sich in ein Team integrieren können, dass sie bereit sind, füreinander auf dem Platz einzustehen, wenn jemand mal einen Fehler macht, dass der nächste halt den ausbügelt. Ich glaube, das ist schon grundsätzlich die Idee. Aber natürlich stecke ich da nicht so tief drin, um jetzt solche Informationen halt geben zu können. Du könntest mich in ein paar Wochen vielleicht nochmal fragen, dann habe ich vielleicht ein paar Internas mehr.
Na ja, gut, erst mal, also, du kannst mir sehr gerne auch da noch Interna stecken, da stehe ich drauf. Aber erst mal interessiert mich ja, wie neben die Fans es war, und da bist du ja dann eben der perfekte Gesprächspartner. Und wenn man dann eben einfach von außen, dass er so danach aussieht, dass es eben eine geschlossene Einheit ist, und ja klar, kicken sollen sie alle können, das ist mir schon auch klar. Und wahrscheinlich sind sie ja auch alle tendenziell jünger als älter. Aber das ist ja dann, reicht ja dann erst mal. Und wenn man dann so einen Fußball damit spielen lassen kann, dann ist es ja auch gut. Was glaubst du, wo landet der FCM am Ende der Saison?
Also ich denke schon, dass wir in einer ähnlichen Region landen, wie wir gerade stehen, also zwischen Platz 5 bis 9, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Wenn das allerdings gelingt, mehr Konstanz reinzukriegen und diese Fehler in der Abwehr abzustellen, dann könnte es auch durchaus noch ein kleines Stückchen weiter hochgehen.
Sehr, sehr mutige Prognose. Und dann stellt sich die Frage Anna. Wenn Magdeburg zwischen Platz 5 und 9 landet am Ende der Saison, wird Schalke 04 am Ende der Saison vor oder hinter Magdeburg stehen?
Stand jetzt hinter Magdeburg.
Das ist jetzt für eine langweilige Antwort. Also wirklich, das kann ich auch.
Ich kann eine Tabelle lesen.
Das ist die Antwort, die ich jetzt gebe.
Natürlich ist mein Traum eine andere Tabellenregion oder eine andere Platzierung.
Eins oder zwei nehme ich mal an.
Eins bis drei.
Aktuell sind wir auf dem 16. Tabellenplatz. Mit sieben Punkten.
Mit sieben Punkten aus acht Spielen und ohne Trainer. Also zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden und fünf Niederlagen waren zu viel für Thomas Reis. Warum musste Thomas Reis jetzt gehen?
Ich glaube, menschlich hat es auch nicht mehr so gepasst am Ende. Aber es ging vor allem um sein Spielsystem, was sehr kritisiert wurde, nicht nur von Fans, sondern auch aus internen Kreisen offenbar auch. Ich bin da jetzt nicht so drin. Ich will da auch keine falschen Informationen weitergeben. Ich glaube, es ging vorweg um sein Spielsystem, was dann schlussendlich dazu geführt hat, dass diese Trennung jetzt vollzogen wurde.
Genau, und es gab eben dieses Interview von Timo Baumgartel, der sehr offen gesagt hat, singenmäßig die Mannschaft weiß gar nicht so wirklich, was sie spielen soll und was soll das hier eigentlich alles. Und dann wurde er dafür bestraft, sodass dann natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit nicht reden. Und dann wurde Thomas Reis entlassen. Und wie ist der Stand jetzt mit Timo Baumgartel? Hat er die Strafe, die er zahlen musste, wieder zurückbekommen, weil sie gesagt haben, ja, du hattest ja eigentlich recht? Oder darf er jetzt wieder mittrenieren?
Nein, er trainiere wieder bei den Profis mit. Er war ja bei der U23, aber die Geldstrafe hat er natürlich trotzdem gezahlt. Genau. Er hat eine Woche bei der U23 mittrainiert und ist seit zwei Tagen wieder bei den Profis mit dabei.
Okay, also das Spielsystem und eben auch der Umgang mit der Mannschaft haben nicht gepasst. Jetzt gucke ich mir das Spielsystem an. Und das ist ein 4-3-3. Und dann gucke ich mir, was hat Schalke so gespielt? Viele lange Bälle, Mannendeckung über den ganzen Platz. Und dann überlege ich mir, was hat Thomas Reis beim VfB gemacht? Ach so, 4-3-3, mit Mannendeckung über den ganzen Platz und langen Bällen. Also, was hat sich denn da jetzt nochmal verändert? Ist es einfach nur, weil der sportliche Erfolg ausgeblieben ist? Weil eigentlich ist es doch genau das, was man von Thomas Reis immer schon gesehen hat. Oder ist es nochmal schlechter geworden?
Ich glaube, dass die Leute vielleicht gedacht haben, dass er das verändert in der 2. Liga, so sein System. Und dann ist der Erfolg ausgeblieben, weil hätte mir vor der Saison jemand gesagt, dass wir aus sieben Spielen nur sieben Punkte holen, hätte ich gesagt, nein, auf gar keinen Fall, das wird nicht passieren, aber es ist nun mal passiert. Und dann ist es auf Schalke einfach ganz schnell so, dass die Stimmung kippt in eine ganz andere Richtung, als sie vielleicht am Anfang der Saison noch war. Ich glaube, da ist es letztendlich daran gescheitert.
Und wie denkst du da jetzt drüber? Also du hast ja schon angedeutet, sinngemäß, es war jetzt alternativlos oder nicht wirklich überraschend. Gleichzeitig wissen wir ja aber auch aus der Vergangenheit, gerade aus der Schalke Vergangenheit, Kränerwechsel waren jetzt nicht immer die Lösung.
Ja, also Schalke ist gerade wieder ein sehr brodelnder Kessel, der kurz davor ist, wieder über zu kochen. Ich wünsche mir auch, und ich glaube, da spreche ich für viele Konstanz auf dieser Position seit Jahren oder auch auf anderen Positionen im Verein. Aber dieser Verein bringt das mit sich. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so etwas jemand auf Schalke geben wird. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, wie es jetzt erstmal weitergehen soll, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin. Ich dachte, dass vielleicht schon im Spiel gegen Paderborn eine Veränderung sichtbar ist. Thomas Reis wurde zwei Tage vor dem Spiel entlassen und Matthias Kreuzer jetzt zu sagen, Ende mal in zwei Tagen alles, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen utopisch. Aber leider war das wieder sehr aussagend, der Auftritt dort von Schalke. Und jetzt muss man schauen, was in den nächsten Spielen passiert. Und vor allem, nächste Woche muss der neue Trainer da sein, weil Matthias Kreuzer das nicht länger machen darf. Wer dann nächste Woche bei Schalke an der Seitenlinie steht, da bin ich auch gespannt.
Und man darf nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Tagen machen.
Genau, er darf nur für zwei Spiele auf der Bank sitzen.
Aber lassen wir noch kurz beim Sportlichen bleiben, weil über Trainer spekulieren ist sowieso so brotlos irgendwie. Aber was hat denn dann in Paderborn gefehlt bei dem 1 zu 3?
Ich habe das Spiel nicht ganz so ausführlich sehen können, weil ich im Zug saß und die interne Verbindung nicht so gut war. Aber es war wieder dieses offensive, ideenlose, dass denen vorne nichts eingefallen ist, wie sie den Ball irgendwie gescheit ins Tor bringen können.
Also das, was man quasi auch schon im Braunschweig gesehen hat, zu Hause gegen Kiel war es glaube ich auch so.
Ja, riesige Lücken im Mittelfeld. Es ist einfach nicht so leicht, gerade das in Worte zu fassen.
Ja, und du sagst, dass es schon wieder sehr brodelt auf Schalke. Da hat man auch schnell ungute Assoziationen, weil ich meine, da gab es halt die Spieler, die über den Parkplatz gejagt wurden. Ist es schon die Art von Brodeln? Weil in der Erstligasaison gab es ja schon so eine Art Schulterschluss, hatte ich das Gefühl, zwischen Fans und Team. Hat sich das jetzt schon wieder so stark gedreht, oder wie würdest du das einschätzen?
Ja, also man ist ja ein bisschen mit erhobenen Hauptes abgestiegen am Ende, weil es ja wirklich dann auch nochmal knapp wurde. Hätte man nach der Hinrunde auch nicht gedacht, aber war ja dann so. Und dann war eine Euphorie da. Wir packen jetzt diese Zweitliga-Saison und so weiter. Wir wollen direkt wieder aufsteigen. Es wurde auch so kommuniziert. Und dann sind die Ergebnisse ausgeblieben bzw. dieser Anspruch und Wirklichkeit liegen gerade weit auseinander auf Schalke. Und dann kippt die Stimmung immer ganz schnell, weil dieser Verein eine unglaubliche Emotionalität mitbringt, die sich dann mit der ganzen Kraft ganz oft entlädt. Und das ist in der Vergangenheit oft nicht gut gegangen. So, was du gerade schon gesagt hast, diese Sache nach dem Abstieg vor zwei Jahren als Spieler gejagt worden, ich habe das schon jetzt so die letzten Tage wahrgenommen, dass die Stimmung wieder in eine ganz gefährliche Richtung kippen kann, wenn es so weitergeht mit den Niederlagen. Also da ist nicht mehr so viel. Ich glaube, in Paderborn waren die Ultras dann auch leise. Also es gab dann keinen Support mehr. Und wenn die Ultras leise werden, dann sind die wirklich sehr sauer.
Ja klar, es ist eine Banalität, aber es stimmt ja. Aber es ist halt irre, wie schnell das jetzt schon wieder auf Schalke ging. Ich meine natürlich, die sportlichen Ergebnisse sind dafür zuständig. Also das weiß ich schon auch. Aber trotzdem ist es einfach… Sonst hätte ich jetzt nicht Schalke schon wieder als Schwerpunkt gemacht. Wenn das alles von außen eindeutig zu verstehen wäre, dann hätte es das nicht gebraucht. Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja auch so größere Fragen, finde ich, bei Schalke 04 noch. Und da müssen wir jetzt gar nicht… Heute müssen wir gar nicht in die Finanzen einsteigen. Da habe ich gar keine Lust drauf. Das haben wir oft genug gemacht im Rasenfunk. Die Finanzen sind schlecht. Mehr muss man, glaube ich, jetzt aktuell nicht wissen. Aber dann kommt eben zum Beispiel sowas. Also wir haben einmal Timo Baumgartel, der quasi so einen Blick in die Kabine gibt. Und der Blick ist sehr schonungslos und führt letztendlich vielleicht auch zumindest partiell auch dafür, dass Thomas Reis entlassen wird. Und dann haben wir mit Frank Kramer aber ja noch einen ehemaligen Trainer, der jetzt einen Blick in den Verein gegeben hat, der ein sehr kritisches Interview gegeben hat. Natürlich nur aus seiner Sicht heraus, aber ist ja klar, welche andere Perspektive er abbilden soll. Gab es in dem Interview Dinge, wo du sagst, das hättest du so auch nicht erwartet, oder endlich spricht es mal jemand an? Wie hast du seine Aussagen wahrgenommen? Und was waren für dich so die wichtigsten Dinge in diesem Interview?
Ich glaube, er hat das schon sehr präzise formuliert, was schief läuft.
Kannst du das nochmal mit deinen Worten zusammenfassen für diejenigen, die das Interview nicht gelesen haben?
Frank Kramer hat ein Interview gegeben, es war auch ein bisschen längeres Interview, beim Kicker, und hat nochmal über seine Zeit auf Schalke gesprochen. Er war ja auch nicht besonders lange Trainer, hatte auch eine relativ kurze Amtszeit. Und wurde dann auch darauf angesprochen, wie seine Reaktion war, als Thomas Reis jetzt entlassen wurde. Und hat auch so ein bisschen auf die Strukturen verwiesen, die auf Schalke sind und wie in manchen Stellen dort vielleicht gearbeitet wird. Also was Kommunikation vor allem angeht. Genau. Und hat dann noch mal ein bisschen mit einigen Personen so ein bisschen abgerechnet, sage ich jetzt mal. Ich habe das Interview jetzt nicht ganz detailreich gelesen, aber natürlich darüber gelesen. Ja, genau. Und dann, das ist das Problem mit auf Schalke, glaube ich, dass ganz oft von außen viele Stimmen dann auch kommen. Das war ja auch die Sache mit Ralf Fehrmann zum Beispiel und seinem Berater. Da gab es ja auch schon was, was ein bisschen Zündstoff gegeben hat. Ich glaube, das hat sich jetzt alles so nach oben geschaukelt, teilweise, dass dann am Ende die Entscheidung war, Thomas Reis muss jetzt gehen. Selbst Summe aus ganz vielen Faktoren, die da zusammengekommen sind.
Aber wie bewertest du sowas? Also zum Beispiel hat Frank Kammer gesagt, das ist nur ein Beispiel, Zitat, aber so ist eigentlich das ganze Interview, Zitat. Im Tagesgeschäft sowie der mittelfristigen und langfristigen Strategie mangelt es Vorstand und Aufsichtsrat an Kompetenz. Sonst würde der Verein nicht immer einmal links und einmal rechts abbiegen. Und wenn Sportdirektoren und Trainer ständig gewechselt werden, wirft das kein gutes Licht auf die obersten Entscheider im Klub. Wenn Trainer und Spieler in sportlich schlechteren Phasen an den Pranger gestellt werden, muss man hinterfragen, wer sie ausgesucht hat. Er spricht viel über Peter Knebel, aber eben auch über den Aufsichtsrat zum Beispiel. Glaubst du, das ist eine Minderheitenmeinung? Oder würdest du jetzt –ich meine, wir können es nur aus der Fahne beurteilen, aber würdest du auch sagen, dass das eines der Probleme auf Schalke ist, dass eben an der obersten Spitze des Vereins zu wenig, ja vielleicht strategische Geduld steckt? Also dass man eben immer so einen Schlingerkurs fährt.
Ja, das würde ich auch so sagen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das eine Minderheitenmeinung ist, die Frank Kramer da gesagt oder zitiert hat. Ich denke schon, dass viele so diesen Blick darauf haben. Auf Schalke möchte man erfolgreich sein, weil wir natürlich vor Gründung der Bundesliga sehr erfolgreich waren, was Meistertitel angeht, weil wir den UEFA Cup 1997 gewonnen haben, weil wir 2001 vier Minuten lang Meister waren. Und man möchte, glaube ich, an diese alten Erfolge anknüpfen. Aber es klappt nicht mehr. Weil, wie gesagt, da viele Faktoren zusammenkommen. Du hast ja gesagt, über das Finanzielle reden wir nicht, aber das ist natürlich auch ein Faktor. Und ich glaube, dass dann oft sehr vorschnell irgendwelche Entscheidungen getroffen werden, ohne dabei längerfristig an die Zukunft zu denken.
Ja, ich meine, Erfolg wollen ja alle. Wenn wir jetzt Jörg fragen, was will der 1. FC Magdeburg, er würde ja nicht sagen, die wollen so Larifari durch die Saison kommen. Nee, jeder will Erfolg haben. Aber die Frage ist ja quasi, mit welchen Mitteln möchte man diesen Erfolg erreichen? Was ist die Strategie? Und da hatte man ja mal eine bei Schalke 04. Das war der eigene Nachwuchs. Dann wurde der aber auch systematisch immer schlechter. Dann kam es dazu, dass so jemand wie Norbert Elgert dann Alarm geschlagen hat und gesagt hat, mit den Leuten hier wird das nichts. Da werden wir in der A-Junioren-Bundesliga keine Chance mehr haben. Dann hat man angefangen, das, was andere Vereine schon früher gemacht haben, auch in diesem Alter schon Transfers zuzukaufen. Was man ja eigentlich nicht machen möchte, ist ehrlich gesagt auch ein Armutszeugnis für ein NLZ, wenn man sich so spät in der U19 noch irgendwelche Spieler verpflichten muss oder sogar noch später in der U23. Aber jetzt ist ja auch schon länger, wenn mir jetzt nicht jemand durchgerutscht ist, niemand mehr nachgekommen aus diesem Nachwuchsbereich, obwohl das ja immer so das Prunkstück von Schalke war. Und ja auch so ein bisschen der finanzielle Notnagel, der immer wieder durch Verkäufe Schalke so ein bisschen am Leben erhalten hat. Was glaubst du ist die aktuelle Strategie, um Erfolg zu haben?
Ich glaube, dass jetzt wieder verstärkt auf die Knappenschmiede gesetzt wird, weil Peter Knebel ja auch eigentlich ursprünglich in der Knappenschmiede gearbeitet hat. Und da seine Stärken auch hat, würde ich jetzt sagen, die aktuelle Strategie ist, glaube ich, einfach aus den vorhandenen Mitteln, die man gerade hatte, irgendwie das Optimale rauszuholen. Und im aktuellen Kader ist ja ein Spieler aus der Knappenschmiede, Assane Uwe Draogo, der natürlich auch eingeschlagen ist, wie sonst was. Aber ja, es stimmt schon, dass dieser Bereich, für den Schalke oft gelobt wird oder wurde, die Jugendarbeit, weil da viele Spieler hervorgegangen sind, vernachlässigt wurde, in den letzten Jahren.
Die Konkurrenz ist da auch größer geworden. Die Art und Weise, wie da gescoutet wird, ist ganz anders. Also da kommen verschiedene Punkte mit rein, für die auch zum Teil dann Schalke 04 gar nichts kann. Also da kann man mit anderen NSZ-Leitern sprechen. Der Wettbewerb ist einfach größer geworden, weil eben wenn Bayern und Dortmund schon 16 Jahre gescouten, dann erhöht das auch den Druck auf alle anderen. Und wenn ein Florian Würz schon mit 16 aus Köln rausgekauft wird, nach Leverkusen und so weiter und so fort. Wie würdest du denn den Kader beschreiben? Weil du hast jetzt gerade schon mit Uwe Drago… Ja, eigentlich ja nicht, aber ich stolper da immer. Hast du ja schon einen genannt. Würdest du denn sagen, das ist ein Kader, mit dem man rein theoretisch überhaupt aufsteigen könnte? Ich meine, dass man jetzt gerade davon 8 Punkte entfernt ist, das ist ja was anderes, aber es sind ja auch nur nur 8 Punkte. Es ging ja rein theoretisch schon. Ist der Kader gut genug dafür, oder wäre er gut genug dafür?
Ja, ich schätze den Kader schon so ein, dass er gut genug dafür ist. Ich glaube, viele würden sagen, der Kader ist ein bisschen alt, aber das heißt ja nicht unbedingt was Schlechtes, so finde ich. Ja, also wir haben aber auch einige Pflichtungen getätigt, die gut eingeschlagen haben. Marius Müller zum Beispiel, der jetzt leider verletzt ist, was auch echt wehgetan hat, die Verletzungen, das war auch im Magdeburg-Spiel, als er sich verletzt hat und natürlich jetzt auch erstmal ausfällt. Ja, Uedra Ogo ist natürlich so ein bisschen das neue Wunderkind. Da muss man auch aufpassen, dass es nicht so krass gehypt wird, glaube ich. Und ansonsten Kenan Karaman hat auch sehr überzeugend gespielt. Jetzt war er auch verletzt, kommt aber wieder zurück. Und gerade ist natürlich auch, was die Stürmer-Situation angeht, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich das diese Saison sage, dass Sebastian Polter vor Simon Terode ist, weil Terode jetzt natürlich auch verletzt war und jetzt aber wieder im Training ist und wahrscheinlich auch am Sonntag spielen wird. Aber ja, gerade hat Sebastian Polter die Nase vorn. Er ist unser bester Torschützer.
Ja, drei Tore Polter und zwei Tore Terode ist aktuell der Zwischenstand. Aber wenn der Kader da ist –und ich meine, man kann, glaube ich, auf diesen Kader so blicken. Ich meine, es gibt schon ein paar Fragezeichen. Also für mich ist so ein typischer Schalke-Spieler aktuell so Danny Latza. Man hat schon mal gesehen, dass er ein guter Spieler ist. Der hat auch einen Grund, warum er wieder zu Schalke gewechselt ist von Mainz 05. Ja, auch in einer für Mainz damals noch ziemlich schwierigen, angespannten Lage hat er ja schon früh diesen Wechsel bekannt gegeben zu den quasi schon sicher abgestiegenen Schalkern. Und trotzdem habe ich ihn noch nie auf Schalke, allerdings, ich gucke natürlich nicht alle Schalke-Spiele, aber ich habe ihn noch nie in der alten Form gesehen auf Schalke. Und ich finde, von dieser Art Spieler gibt es schon mehrere. Wo man sich denkt, ja, also der Theorie nach kannst du richtig, richtig gut Fußball spielen und könntest auch sehr gut in diese Liga passen, aber man sieht es vielleicht ein bisschen zu selten. Oder bin ich da jetzt zu ungerecht?
Ne, das ist wirklich so. Es gibt natürlich auch Fragezeichen auf Positionen, zum Beispiel Rechtsverteidiger. Wir haben einen Rechtsverteidiger, einen gelernten, mit Brunner. Matricciani, Henning Matricciani, muss der Backup-Spieler für alle Verteidigungspositionen sein, gefühlt, wirklich. Wenn jemand ausfällt, ja, der Henning, der macht das schon. So wird auf Schalke gedacht, wenn jemand ausfällt. Ich glaube, dass im Winter da auch nochmal nachgerüstet werden muss, eigentlich. Genau, und wie gesagt, ich glaube, viele denken, dass der Kader ein bisschen zu alt ist. Weil, als wir im Rasenfunk Royale gesprochen haben, bin ich noch davon ausgegangen, dass Simon Terode den FC Schalke verlässt. Und eine Woche später kam die sehr überraschende Vertragsverlängerung, die aus einem emotionalen Aspekt natürlich total schön war. Aber aus einem sportlichen Aspekt glaube ich, ich weiß nicht, ob Simon Terode sein Potenzial, was er vor zwei Jahren in der 2. Liga hatte, jetzt noch abrufen kann. Weil er natürlich auch älter geworden ist. Ist einfach so.
Er ist halt 35.
Genau. Und wir hatten auch sehr schmerzhafte Abgänge mit Marius Bülter und Rodrigo Salazar unter anderem. Was Schalke in der 2. Liga vor zwei Jahren so stark gemacht hat, war die Kombination aus Marius Bülter und Simon Therodde. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, dass es die jetzt nicht mehr gibt.
Der Marius Bülter war übrigens auch mal bei uns.
Genau, ja, stimmt.
Der war auch bei uns sehr hoch angesehen, weil er sich immer mit allem, was er hatte, reingehauen hat, wie man so schön sagt. Der ging nie vom Platz, dass er nicht völlig fertig aussah, hoch roter Kopf. Und der wurde bei uns auch gefeiert. Ein toller Spieler.
Das kann ich nur bestätigen.
Den muss man einfach mögen, die Art Fußball zu spielen und eben auch zu arbeiten.
Der ist immer bis ans Limit gegangen. Der hatte immer die besten Laufwerte von allen aus der Mannschaft letzte Saison. Der hat wirklich immer geackert.
Wir haben eine ganz seltsame Transferhistorie, weil er nur bei Teams gespielt hat, wo ein emotionales Umfeld das richtig wertschätzt. Magdeburg, Union, Schalke. Und jetzt ist er in Hoffenheim. Findet die Puante selbst, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber gut, das ist für wann anders mal wieder Zeit, das im Rasenfunk zu besprechen. Aber Anna, was machen wir denn dann mit Schalke? Also der Kader alt, aber rein theoretisch potenzial da. Wir haben wahrscheinlich Probleme, mindestens in der internen Kommunikation, vielleicht auch quasi im Vorstand, im Aufsichtsrat, dass da die Linie nicht klar genug ist. Vielleicht ist es aber auch unmöglich, als Schalke 04 eine klare Linie zu haben. Vielleicht ist Schalke in einer Situation, wie viele andere Bundesligisten auch. Sie müssen einfach hoffen, dass der Erfolg kommt, indem sie ganz viele Dinge probieren. Hier mal irgendwie einen jungen Spieler, da ein bisschen was aus dem Nachwuchs. Hier mal ein Transfer von jemandem, der es woanders nicht geschafft hat, aber schon etabliert war. Hier mal einen Jungen holen. Das ist ja eigentlich die Strategie von denen meistens. Und das kann ja auch funktionieren. Aber jetzt haben wir ja noch die Trainerfrage offen. Und der letzte Trainer, der funktioniert hat, war Mike Büskens, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Muss es so jemand sein? Kann es nur noch so jemand mit Schalke 04 schaffen, da vielleicht mal –Achtung, nicht gleich wieder lachen –Konstanz reinzubehören?
Ja, vielleicht. Ich denke schon. Aber Mike Büskens wird es nicht nochmal machen.
Weil? Möchte er nicht?
Er möchte nicht, nein. Das hat er auch klar kommuniziert. Aber vielleicht muss es so eine Art –Ich glaube, Mike Büskens hat diesen Aufstieg geschafft vor zwei Jahren auch über diese gewissen emotionalen Aspekte und das Team irgendwie so mitgenommen. Vielleicht muss es so ein Trainer sein, der das Team ein bisschen auf Vordermann bringt.
Und könntest du dir auch vorstellen –Ich weiß, dass das jetzt hypothetisch ist, aber es interessiert mich wirklich –Könntest du dir denn auch vorstellen, dass Schalke 04-mal einen Trainer holt wie Urs Fischer, also damals als er zur Union ist, also unbekannt, kommt aus einer anderen Liga, aber steht für einen klaren Fußball? Oder so jemanden, der etwas aufbauen darf? Also jetzt Fabian Hürzeler baut ja bei St. Pauli was auf. Das werden wir gleich noch ausführlicher besprechen. Aber jemand, wo man eben einfach sagt, der steht für eine bestimmte Art Fußball, das könnte gut passen. Und dem geben wir jetzt die Zeit, auch wenn es zwischendurch richtig wehtun wird, und wir vielleicht den direkten Wiederaufstieg dann mal liegen lassen.
Ja, ich denke, dass Schalke das irgendwann mal schaffen wird, so an die Sache ranzugehen. Und ich wünsche mir das auch.
Aber jetzt schon? Also ich bin mir da selber nicht sicher, ob sie sich das überhaupt leisten könnten, jetzt nicht direkt aufzusteigen. Und ob man dann nicht wieder zu jemandem neigt, der vielleicht kurzfristiger eher den Erfolg bringt.
Also es ist kein Weltuntergang, wenn man nicht direkt wieder aufsteigt. So wurde das zumindest kommuniziert. Aber das ist natürlich der Wunsch und auch das ausgesprochene Ziel, was jetzt schon mehrmals definiert wurde. Und für viele Aspekte wäre der direkte Wiederaufstieg einfach die bessere Option als ein weiteres Jahr in Liga 2.
Und weil wir jetzt die ganze Zeit nur über Aufstieg gesprochen haben müssen, müssten wir in diesem Segment eigentlich auch über Abstieg sprechen? Weil aktuell ist man ja auf Rang 16.
Ja, darüber habe ich noch nicht so viel nachgedacht, weil das eine ganz, ganz schreckliche Vorstellung ist. Das kann man ja gar nicht anders sagen. Ja, aber wenn es so weitergeht, muss man sich natürlich auch Gedanken darüber machen, dass Schalke so ergeht wie Arminia Bielefeld zum Beispiel.
Ich meine, es ist noch sehr viel Saison zu spielen. Ich will da jetzt nichts an die Wand malen. Aber ich will halt auch nicht den Fehler machen, das so komplett auszublenden. Denn jetzt spielt man zu Hause gegen Hertha, beim KSC, zu Hause gegen Hannover, im Pokal auf St. Pauli und dann bei Nürnberg. Ich meine, gut wenigstens bei Nürnberg gewinnt man in der Regel eigentlich immer. Zumindest die letzten Duelle hat, glaube ich, Schalke da immer gewonnen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ansonsten ist das schon, das kann dann schon so sein, dass dann quasi dann das Heimspiel gegen Elbersberg, dass da dann schon wieder ein Riesendruck drauf ist für den neuen Trainer, der bis dahin gefunden sein muss. Und dann sieht man mit Elbersberg gerade eine Mannschaft, die halt gar nichts zu verlieren hat, die überall hinfährt und sagt, also wir gucken jetzt einfach mal, was hier geht. Ach so, ja verrückt, wir haben dreifach gepunktet. Witzig, jetzt fahren wir wieder nach Hause und sie zerlassen quasi ein Trümmerfeld, weil die Leute es nicht fassen können, dass sie gegen Elbersberg verloren haben.
Ja, der Druck ist natürlich einfach immer da bei dem Verein. Immer. In jedem Spiel. Und jetzt gerade ist er natürlich immens. Also es ist ja auch natürlich auch viel davon abhängig, wie das Spiel am Sonntag jetzt ausgeht gegen Hertha, was auf gar keinen Fall einfach wird. Und wie du schon gerade gesagt hast, den Spielplan danach für Schalke, es kommen sehr, sehr schwere Aufgaben auf den Verein zu.
Also, wir werden es angucken. Ich meine, Schalke ist Schalke. Es kann in alle Richtungen ausschlagen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, Anna, dass wir im Frühjahr nochmal über Schalke sprechen und dann drüber sprechen. Meine Güte, wie seid ihr denn jetzt wieder im Aufstiegsrennen gelandet? Ihr habt den Magdeburg von der Eins verdrängt. Das ist ja verrückt. Wie ging denn das? Aber ich kann mir genauso vorstellen, dass wir in ein paar Monaten exakt nochmal so ein Segment aufnehmen. Nur dann haben wir schon den 24. Spieltag und alles ist ein bisschen enger als jetzt. Wir werden es ja eh nicht wissen. Aber ich fand das schön, mal mit euch beiden so ein bisschen in die Fernsehen zu blicken und ihr auch unterschiedliche Stimmungen da wahrzunehmen. Ich danke euch beiden sehr für die Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt, für den Rasenfunk. Danke, liebe Anna, dass du immer wieder hier warst. Und ich hoffe wirklich, wir müssen nicht über den Abstand sprechen. Herzlichen Dank an Jörg Ruffert. Danke dir, lieber Jörg, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Und dass ich sogar so frech sein durfte, einfach dich nochmal kurz die Vereinsgeschichte nach erzählen zu lassen. Das war schon ein bisschen ohne Vorenkündigung ein bisschen hart. Danke, dass du hier warst. Und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit St. Pauli. Und wir machen jetzt weiter hier mit dem Tabellenführer. Das ist natürlich unglücklich, dass der erst jetzt dran kommt. Wir gehen immer nach Tabelle, lieber Tim. Und jetzt mussten wir das so hinten an die Sendung dranpacken. Aber, ehre wem, ehre gebührt, St. Pauli, einziges Team in dieser zweiten Liga, das noch ungeschlagen ist. 16 Punkte aus 8 Spielen. Hallo Tim, von Milan Thun, schon, dass du hier bist.
Ja, freut mich total, hier zu sein. Also auch als Tabellenführer. Es fühlt sich sehr gut an.
Es fühlt sich sehr gut an und ich muss sagen, es ist nicht so überraschend, zumindest wenn man St. Pauli ein bisschen näher verfolgt hat. Ich hatte das schon so mit auf dem Schirm, dass sich da bei Hürzeler auch ganz viel in der Spielanlage verändert hat. Dann hatte ich das große Glück, neben dir das Spiel gegen Heustan Kiel sehen zu dürfen. Ob das glückbar war, weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
So viel, wie ich gesammelt habe.
Es war quasi wie ein Tribügengespräch, bei dem ich nur der Zuhörende bin. Aber da hast du mir einfach mal schön in 90 Minuten alles erklärt. Und unsere große Herausforderung wird jetzt, Tim, dass wir das jetzt nochmal wiederholen müssen. Aber in 20 Minuten? Kannst du das schaffen? Das ist jetzt quasi wie bei Star Trek. Sie haben, es dauert 3 Tage, bis der Warpantrieb geht. Du hast 30 Minuten. Okay, ich schaff's in 5. So wird's jetzt hier laufen müssen. Also, was ist denn die besondere Fabian-Hürzeler-Note oder warum liegt St. Pauli ungeschlagen, mit 13 zu 5 Toren, ja auch wirklich relativ souverän an der Spitze der Tabelle?
Ja, da müssen wir den Bogen, glaube ich, zur letzten Saison aufschlagen. Fabian Hürzeler hat ja zur Rückrunde 22, 23 übernommen und dann ist er ja auch sofort durchgestartet mit zehn Siegen in Serie. Und wenn man das so aus ein paar Dingen runterbricht, dann fangen wir einmal bei dieser defensiven Stabilität an. Ich glaube, der hat jetzt, ganz genau weiß ich es nicht, in 25 Ligaspielen hat er 19 Gegentore bekommen, also der FC St. Pauli und auch Fabian Hürzeler. Und das ist natürlich eine überragende Quote. Und bemerkenswert ist dabei, dass er es irgendwie geschafft hat. Oder was heißt irgendwie? Na, also irgendwie hat er seine Spieler, das Team, auf einer Ebene zu fassen bekommen, dass sie es als extrem motivierend empfinden, defensiv zu arbeiten, auch gegen den Ball zu arbeiten. Diese Umschaltmomente, also wenn es defensive Umschaltmomente für St. Pauli gibt, dann ist das schon, ich würde sagen, schon fast so ein bisschen wie Atletico Madrid, alle im Vollspring zurück hinter dem Ball. Das ist schon bemerkenswert mit anzuschauen. Und deswegen habe ich mal den Fehler gemacht und ihn Fabian Hötzler als defensiv denkenden Trainer bezeichnet, weil das halt der krasseste Schalter gewesen ist, den man auch, muss man ehrlich sagen, zu Timo Schulz, der ja auch offensiv tolle Ideen hatte, aber defensiv ja das einfach nicht hinbekriegt hat, das stabil zu bekommen, weil das schon so ein krasser Unterschied war, was Fabian Hötzler da implementiert hat bei St. Pauli. Eben, dass dieses Team so defensiv, so stabil geworden ist. Aber ein defensiv denkender Trainer, da wehrt er sich vehement gegen und das kann ich auch verstehen.
Ja, ich denke, das wird dann deutlicher, wenn wir dann auch über die Offensive sprechen. Aber ist es quasi nur die Einstellung der Spieler, weil wenn man sich zum Beispiel Defensiv-Statistiken anguckt, also jenseits der Gegentore, die man gefangen hat, das ist natürlich super. Fünf Gegentreffer nach acht Spielen. Und du hast ja gesagt, das ist ein Trend, der sich quasi fortsetzt, auch aus der letzten Saison heraus. Aber die Defensiv-Statistiken für sich genommen sind gar nicht so krass. Also es gibt nur ein Team, das weniger Taglinks ausführt pro Spiel als St. Pauli. Das ist die Spielvereinigung Greuther Fürth. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, dass dann viel durch Stellungsspiel offensichtlich gelohnt wird. Man lässt jetzt nicht so viele Schüsse aufs eigene Tor zu. Aber ich glaube, auch da ist man jetzt nicht absolut herausragend gut. Also was ist es denn dann?
Na ja, du hast die Antwort im Grunde schon gegeben. Es ist tatsächlich das Stellungsspiel. St. Pauli schafft es oft gegen Hertha jetzt am Wochenende, letzte Wochenende war das total eklatant, dass St. Pauli gerade in so einer Phase nach Wiederanpfiff bis zum 2-0 haben die wirklich, ich glaube, also ich erinnere mich an keinen Ball, den Hertha ins letzte Drittel bekommen hat. St. Pauli hat die alle abgefangen, die Pässe. Und du sagst, ja klar, mit den Taglings, da machen sie weniger. Das stimmt auch, da sind sie auch gar nicht so gut, ne? Also Quoten haben auch gar nicht so eine gute Quote, was das angeht. Aber haben es dann doch, ja schaffen es dann doch, da gar nicht rein zu müssen. Da sind so Spieler wie Hauke Wahl oder so, der schafft das eher dann über gutes Stellungsspiel, das zu lösen mit ein bisschen weniger Tempo. Dafür aber ja dann doch mit gutem Stellungsspiel. Im zentralen Mittelfeld sind sie gut aufgestellt mit Jackson Irvine, der ja viel auch aus der Luft wischt. Und ich würde dann dagegenhalten, ne? St. Pauli lässt die wenigsten gegnerischen Ballkontakte im eigenen Strafraum zu, hat die Gegner schaffen, am wenigsten bringe am wenigsten Pässe zum Mitspieler im Strafraum des FC St. Pauli. Sie haben den niedrigsten Expected-Goals-Wert zugelassen. Die wenigsten Torschüsse oder nicht ganz die wenigsten Torschüsse haben die wenigsten Gegentore gefangen. Also da ist schon viel dabei, was richtig gut ist. Und ja, klar, die Zweikampfstatistiken, die passen da nicht ganz so rein. Da sind die dann mit nur 55 Prozent Quote nicht ganz so gut dabei. Da gibt es Teams, die wesentlich besser vorangekommen sind, bessere Quoten haben. Aber das ist gar nicht so notwendig, wie der Rest dann so zeigt an den Statistiken.
Sollte es etwas sein, dass die Zweikampfstatistik nicht die wichtigste Statistik und Aushalge, die die Statistik ist. Das kann doch gar nicht sein. Die wird uns doch bei jeder Übertragung angezeigt. 51 Prozent zu 49 Prozent. Na, egal. Okay, aber dann lass doch noch ein bisschen auf die Spieler eingehen, die da in der Verteidigung stehen und auf die Art und Weise, wie sie spielen. Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, sie fangen viele Pässe ab. Wir haben eine Fünferkette bei St. Pauli. Und ich würde mal sagen, gegen Heustan Ki, das war auch ein besonderes Spiel, weil da lief eigentlich alles wunderbar in beide Richtungen des Feldes. Aber was da eben zu sehen war, war für mich als jemand, der noch nicht so viele St. Pauli-Spiele gesehen hat diese Saison, in einem gewissen Bereich durfte Heustan ohne Probleme rein, dribbeln, passen, was auch immer. Aber dann spätestens zehn Meter nach der Mittellinie, würde ich sagen, dann war einfach dicht. Dann war Gegnerkontakt da, dann war es vielbeinig. Also da standen dann eben fünf in der letzten Kette und dann oft genügend davor. Oft dann, ich glaube, 5-3-2 was auf gegen Heustan. Das bin ich mir gerade nicht mehr sicher. Da müsste ich nochmal meine Notizen gucken. Aber wer sind da die entscheidenden Spieler und was passiert denn, wenn ich als Gegner ins eigene Angriffstrittel komme? Was passiert dann mit mir?
Genau, das Problem ist tatsächlich meist sogar, schon überhaupt da rein zu kommen. Ich würde das gerade im zentralen Drittel eher als den Fokus bezeichnen, wo sie versuchen, die Bälle zu gewinnen. Das ist ganz richtig mit der Fünferkette. Davor spielen sie dann 5-2-3 meist. Wobei die beiden Äußeren, das sind die offensiven Außensaat und Dapo Afullayan sind das momentan, die dann doch so eine Art Pressing-Falle aufbauen. Die bieten schon den Pass nach außen auf den Außenverteidiger oder Schienenspieler an. Sie fallen dann relativ schnell auf die Außenbahn. Dann wird sich ein 5-4-1 bildet. Dann schieben sie gerade mit diesem 4-1 enorm rüber auf die Seite. Sie lassen die Ballferne Seite, die wird komplett allein gelassen. Das macht dann der rechte Schienenspieler so ein bisschen im Raum. Und da verknappen die dann die Räume. Das ist wie so eine ganz klassische Pressing-Falle. Was dann meist der Gegner macht, ist, einen Ball zurück zu spielen zum Innenverteidiger. Und dann wird halt hoch angelaufen. Das ist so etwas wie ein klassischer Pressing-Auslöser. Also die haben so einen ganz zentralen Fünfer-Block vorne, hinten eine Kette und vorne so ein Fünfer-Block. Ob der jetzt 2-3 steht oder 3-2, das ist dann so ein bisschen variabel, je nachdem, wie tief oder hoch die offensiven Außen da unterwegs sind. Aber in diesem Block bewegen sie sich im Grunde dann zentral übers Feld. Und wenn es dann tiefer geht, dann bildet sich da mit den offensiven Außen die Fallen dann, dann wird das eine Viererkette. Und dann ziehen die aber auch rüber. Und dann gibt es immer wieder Phasen, und du hast vollkommen recht, es gibt Phasen, da lassen sie den Gegner komplett in Ruhe. Also im Grunde, in der eigenen Hälfte ist es, oder ich sag mal, in deren eigenen Drittel, ist es ganz selten nur so, dass sie offensiv angelaufen werden. Nur eben dann, wenn sie die Pressing-Falle gestellt haben, und wenn dann der Rückpass erfolgt, was ja meist auch eine Rückwärtsbewegung für alle gegnerischen Spieler bedeutet, also nicht sonderlich vorteilhaft für so ein Aufbauspiel, für ein organisiertes, das ist dann der Moment, wo sie dann halt hoch anlaufen. Aber davor, wenn sie dann aufbauen, vorm flachen Abstoß oder so, da lassen sie den eigentlich immer relativ viel Zeit. Und dann kommt es natürlich dazu, dass man irgendwie sagen kann, also alle Spiele, die man gesehen hat von St. Pauli, da ist der FC St. Pauli wahnsinnig dominant, er tritt auch total dominant auf. Du siehst das aber nicht in den Ballbesitzquoten, weil sie eben dem Gegner so viel Zeit lassen, aber die ganze Zeit den Finger am Abzug haben, also sie ganz zeitlich Spielkontrolle halten, obwohl der Gegner da viel den Ball hat. Also das ist tatsächlich relativ wenig aussagekräftig, so eine Ballbesitzstatistik. Aber das ist ein ziemlich klares Verhalten, und da habe ich bisher noch kein Team gesehen, das da eine richtige Lösung für gefunden hat.
Aber wie ist es dann, wenn St. Pauli zurückliegt? Weil da kann es ja dann manchmal auch ein Problem sein. Das sehe ich in der ersten Liga oft bei Teams. Welche, die eben die Kontrolle dem Gegner überlassen und darin sehr gut sind, die haben dann ein Problem ab 0 zu 1, weil sie dann rein theoretisch Druck ausüben müssten, und das können sie aber nicht so wirklich.
Also weiß ich nicht, weil St. Pauli ist diese Saison noch nie in den Rückstand geraten. Und es war letztes Jahr, es ist auch ganz selten, wenn der Fabian Hürzler passiert ist, es gab den Niederlei gegen Braunschweig, Niederlei gegen HSV, da lag man zurück, da ist dann ein komplett wildes, offenes Spiel entstanden bei beiden. Braunschweig war dann, die waren nicht, spielerisch nicht so gut, die hat St. Pauli ganz gut hinten reingedrängt, da fehlte dann vorne aber so ein, ja so ein Turm, sag ich mal, so ein klassischer Stoßstürmer. Oder was heißt Stoßstürmer, ein Bandspieler. Viel oft bei den Spielen, auch die, die lange unentschieden standen, da ist dann eben die Frage, wie man da vor allem eher im eigenen Spielaufbau was machen kann. Ob sie dann schneller den Ball gewinnen, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob sie so viel schneller die Bälle dann gewinnen, versuchen zu gewinnen, höher anlaufen, ich glaube eigentlich eher nicht, aber wie gesagt, ich habe es dieses Jahr noch gar nicht gesehen, weil St. Pauli immer in Führung gegangen ist.
Um die Defensive abzuschließen, welchen Spieler muss man da rausnehmen, dass St. Pauli dann ein Problem hat, seine Stabilität zu halten?
Ich dachte, dass es Jackson Irvine ist, der jetzt auch gefehlt hat, weil er der kopfballstärkste Spieler auf der Position ist und zweikampfstark enorm und dem ganzen Team viel Sicherheit gibt und doch schon so ein Stabilitätselement ist, komisches Wort, aber das nutze ich jetzt mal. Stabilisieren das Element so, das wäre besser gewesen. Aber der war es nicht. Also Conor Metcalf hat da jetzt gespielt, ja auch sehr aggressiv in den Zweikämpfungen. Das hat er auch sehr gut gemacht und ich komme jetzt gerade von einer Pressekonferenz und habe da auch gefragt, wen willst du denn eigentlich einsetzen, Metcalf oder Irvine, weil das ist tatsächlich echt so eine Frage. Und es wird Jackson Irvine am Wochenende wieder auf dem Platz stehen, aber Conor Metcalf ist halt einer der 8er in der Liga dabei. Ich würde sagen, 15 von 18 Zweitligisten steht er immer in der Startelf, so momentan bei St. Pauli nicht. Da habe ich gedacht, das ist der Spieler, der darf auf gar keinen Fall ausfallen. Ist er ausgefallen, hat auch keine Rolle gespielt. Und das ist tatsächlich allgemein eine sehr positive Entwicklung beim FC St. Pauli. Und auch nachhaltige Entwicklung, was mich positiv stimmt, dass diese Tabellenführung nicht nur verdient ist und nicht nur eine Momentaufnahme, sondern dass wir uns da oben dauerhaft festsetzen, dass das ganze spielerunabhängig relativ gut funktioniert. Also, dass das nicht so ist, dass man sagt, wenn wir den Spieler verlieren, dann haben wir aber ein Problem. Sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass es viele, viele Spieler gibt, die dann neu reingekommen sind, die dann auf einmal gute Leistung gebracht haben. Und die große Aufgabe für Fabian Hürzler ist, das jetzt zu moderieren. Also, wie willst du jemandem wie Conor Metcalf erklären, du pass auf, du hast super gespielt, aber du musst jetzt trotzdem wieder raus, weil ja, warum eigentlich? Weil Jackson Irvine noch besser ist. Ja, klar ist er. Aber trotzdem haben viele Spieler da das Bedürfnis zu spielen. Also da ist jetzt viel Redebedarf im Team. Also es gibt keinen Spieler, auf den man defensiv achten muss. Es gibt keinen Spieler, den man rausnehmen muss. Es ist tatsächlich in dem Fall das System, und dass alle Spieler, egal welcher von den 24 im Kader, die wissen das alle, wie es funktioniert, und die halten sich da dran, und denen gibt das auch Sicherheit, dass sie genau wissen, wie es funktioniert. Und das ist total eine Stärke, dass das spielerunabhängig funktioniert. Offensiv sehe ich das ein bisschen anders, aber defensiv würde ich sagen, das funktioniert alles, egal wen du da hinstellst aus dem Kader.
Sehr gut, dann lass doch auf die Offensive mal blicken. St. Pauli ist die passsicherste Mannschaft der 2. Liga, aktuell 83%, so ungefähr, die Passquote. Man hat relativ viel Ballbesitz in den vorderen beiden Drittel, also vor allem im mittleren Drittel und im vordersten Drittel. Man hat, glaube ich, die drittmeisten Ballkontakte im gegnerischen Strafraum. Und man ist jemand, der aus dem Spiel heraus sehr viele Schüsse herausspielt und dementsprechend auch Tore. Also da gibt es mit dem KSC noch eine Mannschaft, die tatsächlich noch mehr Schüsse bisher aus dem laufenden Spiel herausgespielt hat. Aber dann kommt schon St. Pauli. Und da ist ein deutlicher Unterschied zu sehen. Zum Beispiel zu so Teams wie –ich weiß nicht, ob dir das ein Begriff ist– HSV. Da gibt es noch so ein Team aus Hamburg, die haben zum Beispiel fast 30 Schüsse weniger aus dem Spiel heraus. Also muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, 8. Spieltag und so weiter und so fort. Hängt noch ein bisschen auch von den Gegnern ab. So, aber wie funktioniert die Offensive von St. Pauli? Und warum sind da manche Spieler eher unersetzbar?
Genau. Also ein Wort, was auf jeden Fall fallen muss in diesem Abschnitt zur Offensive, ist Variabilität. Der FC St. Pauli hat auch schon in der Rückrunde letzte Saison und jetzt mal noch viel mehr in der Hinrunde. Sind sie sehr variabel im Spielaufbau? Wie sie initial aufbauen? Wir fangen mal ganz hinten an. Das ist meist so ein 2-3-Aufbau, also zwei Innenverteidiger. Der 6er oder zentrale Innenverteidiger Eric Smit, der schiebt dann nach vorne in den 6er-Raum und flankiert wird er in den defensiven Halbräumen rechts und links von den Schienenspielern. Das bedeutet auch, dass einer der beiden 6er –St. Pauli spielt mit einer Doppel-6, das sind Hartl und Irvine meist –oder sogar beide 6er, da komme ich schon wieder zur Flexibilität, dass die Freiheiten bekommen, nach vorne gehen. Marcel Hartl, der hat deswegen auch so viele Tore erzielt, weil er im Grunde ein freies Radikal ist und sich da frei bewegt. Aber wir bleiben erstmal bei diesem 2-3-Aufbau. Das ist so eine Möglichkeit da aufzubauen. Da versuchen sie dann über den 6er in den Halbraum zu kommen, die dann aufgedreht sind, und dann weiter auf die Außenbahn zu kommen. Idealerweise, wenn der Gegner nicht gut steht, zu Zentrum fokussiert ist, dann spielen sie auch teilweise aus der Innenverteidigung direkt auf die offensiven Außenpositionen und lösen da Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen aus, was auch ein Ziel ist von denen. Und was man auch machen kann mit Elia Saad und Dapo Afolaian da auf den Außenpositionen, die in Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen zu bekommen. Eine weitere Methode, wenn das nicht so richtig funktioniert, wenn der Gegner das zustellt, ist das, was ich als Deserbi-Aufbauschule bezeichnen würde. Das ist so ein 2-4-Aufbau. Da ist nicht ein Sechser dabei, sondern da sind dann zwei Innenverteidiger und ein Zweisechser dabei. Das ist dann meist Jackson Irvine. Und dann eben die beiden Schienenspieler. Die bilden dann sozusagen ein 2-4-4 im Aufbau. Und können dann darüber haben, auf natürlicher Art und Weise, es sei denn, der Gegner committet sich komplett darauf. Man deckt über den ganzen Platz, hast du eine Überzahl-Situation in dem Bereich. Also kannst du im 6er-Raum immer eine Überzahl-Situation und kannst das auch ausspielen. Und da ist die Spielstärke auch vorhanden, um das zu machen. Es haben jetzt viele Teams versucht, sich dann tatsächlich komplett zu committen, komplett in Mann-Deckung zu gehen. Und da hatte St. Pauli in der Rückrunde letztes Jahr so ein paar Probleme mit, weil eben dieses Überspielen, so Schipp-Bälle vor die letzte Kette der Gegner und so, weil sie dafür nicht den Spieler hatten vorne drin. Das haben sie jetzt versucht mit Andreas Albers, der neu im Sturm dazu gekommen ist, so ein bisschen zu holen. Der hat allerdings noch nicht ganz so eingeschlagen, wie man sich das wahrscheinlich erhofft hat. Aber sie haben mit Maurides auch so einen Spieler drin, der das kann, der da vorne rein kann. Die spielen aber beide momentan nicht, weil es anders viel besser funktioniert. Aber das ist so Stichwort Variabilität. Wenn da Gegner kommen, die so mannorientiert sind, wo es Sinn macht, das zu überspielen, dann sind da auch Spieler im Kader, wo man das mal eben schnell umstellen kann. Das würde dann mit einer Einwechslung funktionieren. Beim FC St. Pauli ist es meist so, dass sie zwischen dem 2-3- und 2-4-Aufbau das ausprobieren während des Spiels. Also mal 2-3, mal 2-4. Sie gucken dann, was funktioniert, und dann überlegen sie, das funktioniert Marcel Hartl, der dann vorne ist. Da habe ich schon gesagt, er ist ein freies Radikal. Der bewegt sich auch gerne mal ganz auf die Außenbahn. Mal spielt er als zweiter Stürmer, mal lässt er sich immer wieder von dieser Stürmerposition in Zehnerraum fallen. Mal geht er auch ganz tief und baut auf der Sechs mit auf, um da Überzahl zu generieren. Und das ist total flexibel. Lars Rizka auf der linken Position, der geht auch gerne nach vorne rein, macht diese tiefen Läufe. Elias Saad, der dann auf der offensiven Außenposition ist, der geht gerne ins 1 gegen 1 auf der Außenbahn, macht aber auch gerne tiefen Läufe, geht auch gerne ins Zentrum. Jackson Irvine ist immer der Spieler, bei dem du darauf achten musst, weil das immer dieser klassische nachrückende Achter ist an den zweiten Pfosten bei tiefen Wellen, der sich aber auch gerne mal ganz tief fallen lässt. Also es ist super flexibel, was da gespielt wird. Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Rollen. Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, was der FC St. Pauli geschafft hat. Im Vergleich zur Rückrunde, da war zwar auch schon viel flexibel und viel Rotation, wer aber am meisten rotiert ist, war Lea Pakarada. Und im Grunde haben alle Spieler des FC St. Pauli auf Lea Pakarada reagiert. Wenn der in den Zehnerraum gegangen ist, wenn der in den Sechserraum gegangen ist, dann haben die immer die Löcher zugemacht. Aber das konntest du machen, war alles okay, weil Lea Pakarada einfach so eine hohe Klasse hatte, dass man das machen konnte, ihm diese Freiheit geben konnte. Jetzt wird das auf mehrere Schultern verteilt, diese Freiheiten. Es ist ein bisschen feiner abgestimmt, da sind bessere Laufwege drin, besseres Verständnis für die Rollen, die einzelne Spieler haben. Und es funktioniert eben auch offensiv mit Spielern, die dann auch länger nicht gespielt haben. Also da ist dieses System, das gibt es in Sicherheit. Fabian Hürzler hat gesagt, auf einer Pressekonferenz vor zwei, drei Wochen, habe ich ihn mal drauf angesprochen. Und er meinte, dass man gerade offensiv, arbeitet er eigentlich nur mit Prinzipien, also gar keine festen Laufwege und Abläufe, sondern nur mit Prinzipien. Und da sind eben sehr spielintelligente Spieler auch drin. Jetzt hat sich momentan Johannes Eggestein da vorne reingespielt, bei dem ich eigentlich immer sagte, gerade so das Defensivspiel, das Pressing-Verhalten, das passt eigentlich nicht ganz so gut. Der hat auch körperliche Nachteile, da hat er versucht, einiges aufzuholen, ist aber, wird nie ein Zielspieler sein. Hat jetzt aber gerade was das Mitspielen, das Zusammenspielen mit Marcel Hartl angeht, enorme Schritte nach vorne gemacht und bringt das Spiel auch nach vorne und hat sich da erstmal festgespielt. Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass der FC St. Pauli noch einen Super-Transfer kurz vor Ende gemacht hat mit Simon Zoller, der hat noch gar nicht gespielt.
Das wollte ich nämlich absprechen. Ich dachte, man darf nicht ohne Mittelstürmer erfolgreich Fußball spielen. Das geht doch eigentlich gar nicht. Wo ist euer Harry Kane?
Ja, genau. Man muss bei Johannes Eggestein schon sagen, dass er unter Fabian Hürzele ganz, ganz wenig gespielt hat. Er hat ein ganz schwieriges halbes Jahr gehabt. Man hat sich oft gefragt, warum ist das eigentlich so? Weil die Zahlen auch von der Hinrunde der letzten Saison, als er eben mehr gespielt hat, nach der Hinrunde waren wir mit fünf Treffern der beste Torschütze. Und deutlich ligaweit der Spieler mit den meisten Ballkontakten im Strafraum. Und auch einer der wenigen Spieler, die einen höheren Expected Goals Wert haben als Tore oder hatten, der es schafft, sowohl im Zusammenspiel mit den Mitspielern da eben ein guter Wandspieler zu sein, auf eine andere Art und Weise, als das eben diese 1,95 Türme sind. Aber er schafft es auch immer wieder in der Box, dann da genau da zu sein, wo eben dieser klassische Mittelstürmer sein muss. Also dieses Raumgefühl hat er auch. Das ist total gut und total wertvoll. Ja, genau, deswegen ist so mit Simon Zoller, hat man gedacht, den braucht man noch. Und jetzt hat man auf einmal währenddessen, während der noch nicht ganz fit war, festgestellt, oh ja, Johannes Eggestein ist ja auch noch da. Und das hat man eben mit ganz vielen anderen Spielern auch festgestellt. Pacarada ist weg, da ist Lars Rizka reingekommen, der zwei Jahre lang hinter Pacarada eigentlich kaum eine Rolle gespielt hat. Und der ist jetzt, also es ist so eine Bank, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Also wie sehr der sich da reingearbeitet hat und auch ja schon im Spielaufbau viel mitmacht und so. Und da können sich viele Spieler werden da tatsächlich an diesem System, an diesem Gerüst, was denen vorgegeben wird, können sich da gut frei drin bewegen und entwickeln sich ganz fantastisch.
Ja, ich meine, das ist schon erstaunlich. Also wenn man sich nur die Zweitligatreffer anguckt, dann gibt es acht Spieler, die schon ein Tor erzielt haben bei St. Pauli, aber nur zwei, die mehr als eins erzielt haben, nämlich Ilea Saad, zwei und Marcel Hartl mit fünf. Also das ist dann, da kommt auch noch so mancher Freistoß mit dazu, wenn ich mich da jetzt nicht gerade komplett falsch erinnere.
Nee, das ist auch, also ich würde auch sagen, also man muss auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt alles Gold ist. Also wenn man davon ausgeht, aber wenn man das als Entwicklungsschritte beattrachtet, dann ist das auch wirklich das letzte Puzzlestück, was ich auch einfügen würde, wenn ich Trainer wäre, wenn du die Mannschaft übernimmst, die sich, die defensiv nicht stabil ist, dann erstmal eine defensive Stabilität reinzubringen. Dann hattest du letzte Saison, hattest du Spieler, die offensiv im Grunde viel alleine gelöst haben. Lukas Daschner, Lea Pakarada, die haben im Offensivspiel, da musste man auch gar nicht so viel mit denen an die Hand geben, damit die da Lösungen finden in der Offensive. Das haben die eigentlich schon von ganz alleine gemacht. Aber dann ist dieses defensive Gerüst, das muss immer wieder stehen. Diese Konterabsicherung, das war ein großes Problem vor Fabian Nutzelaar, die Konterabsicherung. Das hat er jetzt gelöst. Und dann erstmal über die Defensive, über den –und dann ist es im Grunde ja auch ein defensiver Ansatz –sagt er auch super gerne, einer seiner Lieblingssprüche ist immer, wenn wir den Ball haben, kann der Gegner kein Tor schießen. Das ist dann auch so, dann wird so eine Idee bei Ballbesitz entwickelt. Wie können wir den Ball länger halten? Wie kriegen wir, geben wir uns dadurch selber Sicherheit und, und, und. Und dann ist jetzt das letzte Puzzlestück. Du bist dann ein ballbesitzdominantes Team. Du bist defensiv stabil. Und der letzte Schritt ist jetzt das Offensivspiel, was dann sozusagen angegangen wurde, was in der Rückrunde letztes Jahr so ein bisschen von alleine funktionierte. Da musste man dieses Jahr so ein bisschen mehr mit an die Hand geben. Und das ist jetzt so das Spiel im letzten Rittel. Das ist schon gut. Aber es ist noch nicht so, dass ich sage, so damit machen wir alle, also damit wir schießen immer drei Tore. So ungefähr. Also da sind viele so die Entscheidungen, wann St. Pauli Schüsse nimmt. Wir saßen zusammen gegen Kiel im Stadion. Da hat St. Pauli aus vier Fernschusstoren gemacht. Bei dem Freistoß kann man sagen, ja, den kann man schießen. Bei allen anderen würde ich immer sagen, schieß auf keinen Fall, bist du bescheuert. Gerade, wenn die Boxbesetzung irgendwie passt. Da muss man sagen, gerade diese Entscheidungsfindung im letzten Drittel, das Spiel im letzten Drittel, das ist gemessen an dem, was die sonst haben. Die haben die beste Quote, was Pässe ins letzte Drittel angeht. Die schaffen es, total kontrolliert immer ins letzte Drittel reinzukommen. Aber haben dann die Aktionen, die dann ausgelöst werden, dass es dann manchmal nicht ganz so passt, weil die Boxbesetzung nicht passt, weil dann in einigen Momenten die falschen Entscheidungen getroffen werden und und und. Ich rede darüber, während der FC St. Pauli 10 Tore in den letzten drei Spielen gemacht hat. Das muss man dazu auch noch sehen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwas schlecht ist. Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, das ist das Top-Level der Liga. Aber man sieht diese Entwicklung schon. Da geht es auf jeden Fall hin. Man sieht schon, wenn die das jetzt noch schaffen würden, im letzten Drittel mehr richtige Entscheidungen zu treffen, in richtigen Momenten, gerade auch die Spieler auszunutzen, das Einlaufverhalten von Irvine, das Raumverhalten von Johannes Eggestein, der jetzt gerade erst drei Spiele gespielt hat, das hat gegen Hertha schon besser funktioniert. Wenn man das dann noch richtig einsetzt, dann sind wir…
Auf Jahre hin unschlagbar.
Das wirst du nie rankommen, aber dann Franz Beckenbauer auf Jahre unschlagbar.
Ja, ich meine, das liegt natürlich auch ein bisschen daran, dass in der Offensive immer besondere Dinge passieren müssen, dass du den Gegner aus seiner Ordnung bringst, weil die defensiven Abläufe, die sind viel, viel klarer, weil die orientieren sich am Gegner und die offensiven Abläufe, die orientieren sich an den Fähigkeiten der einzelnen Spieler. Letztlich, jetzt übertrieben gesprochen, ich habe natürlich auch ein Spiel gesehen, in dem sehr, sehr viel für St. Pauli gut funktioniert hat, aber ich habe doch auch mitverfolgt, dass St. Pauli gerade mit dem besten Fußball spielt und sogar, würde ich sagen, deutschlandweit. Also ich gucke ja sehr viel Fußball und es gibt manche Zweitligaspiele, die kann man sich sehr, sehr gut angucken und da gehört St. Pauli auf jeden Fall mit dazu. Aber der letzte Schritt, den ihr vielleicht so machen müsstet, ist so dieser Louis-Fanral-FC Bayern-Schritt. Also du bekommst jetzt schon deine Außenspieler in die 1 gegen 1-Duelle. Das sind Afoulaian und Elias Saad vor allem, der einfach ein krasser Kicker ist. Und was dann passiert, weiß niemand. In zwei von drei Fällen gewinnt sie das Tripling irgendwie. Es kann aber sein, dass er über die Innenseite gegangen ist. Es kann sein, dass er an der Grundlinie steht. Also völlig unterschiedlicher Outcome. Und manchmal verliert er auch den Ball. Und dann müssen auch wirklich alle Bock haben, wieder zurückzuarbeiten, auch wenn es nervt, wenn du quasi mit viel Aufwand dahingekommen bist und er dann doch vielleicht auch mal zu viel ins Tripling gegangen ist. Weil das gehörte zu diesem Spieletypen mit dazu. Und was hat Louis-Fanral als Allererstes den Bayern dann beigebracht? Also wir spielen so Ribery und Robben frei. So, jetzt gewinnen die e-Duell. Und was passiert jetzt? Und dann hat er gesagt, okay, also der erste Pfosten ist immer am 5-Meter-Eck gedeckt. Und der zweite Pfosten ist immer zwischen Torhütter und letztem Innenverteidiger. Und der Ball muss aber auch immer dahin kommen. Und die dritte Option ist hinten am Elfmeterpunkt, im Rückraum. Und als Flankengeber, als Ribery, als Robben hast du jetzt, du hast eine Aufgabe. Entweder du nimmst den Abschluss, wenn du quasi nach innen gezogen bist, alles okay. Oder du spielst den Ball und du hast aber nur diese drei Optionen. Und wenn du eine von diesen drei Optionen, also wenn du dir eine vierte ausdenkst, dann werde ich so richtig sauer und dann wechsle ich dich aus. Und dafür habe ich kein Verständnis. Und wenn nicht alle drei Positionen besetzt sind, dann werde ich auch richtig sauer. Also, war vielleicht auch noch eine andere Zeit, andere Trainer-Generationen und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, das wäre so der nächste Schritt, weil das ist das, was du ja auch schon angedeutet hast. Die Achter rücken schon nach, aber es ist so ein bisschen random, an welcher Stelle sie nachrücken. Der Strafraum ist besetzt, aber manchmal auch so ein bisschen häufchenweise und nicht strukturiert. Und das ist ja eigentlich zu schaffen. Und dann kannst du nämlich vielleicht auch noch Simon Zoller da sehr gut integrieren. Eigentlich gibt es keinen Grund, warum der gerade keine Rolle spielt, außer halt, dass die anderen so stark spielen gerade, also formstark.
Ja, irgendwann ist er auch angeschlagen gekommen. Es war jetzt fünf Wochen lang, hat er nicht richtig trainiert. Jetzt hat er gerade richtig trainiert. Ich glaube, Simon Zoller hätte gespielt schon, wenn das jetzt nicht auf einmal so gut laufen würde. Was heißt auf einmal? Es ist ja nicht schlecht gelaufen. Es gab vier unentschiedene Serie. Er hat St. Pauli nicht das Tor getroffen, sich aber durchaus die Chancen erspielt. Aber gerade so diese Chancen erspielt, wenn man schaut, was der Aufwand ist, den sie betreiben und wie hoch der Outcome ist, dann muss man schon sagen, dass da diese Aufs-Box-Besetzung ist. Ja, doch, Box-Besetzung ist ein Thema tatsächlich. Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Fabian Hützler so detailversessen ist. Die werden schon genau wissen, wo sie wann sein sollen. Ich glaube, er dreht das vielleicht eher um und setzt so ein bisschen mehr auf die Radikalität, dass man sagt, wir wollen hier noch weniger ausrechenbar sein. Das ist, glaube ich, eins. Das hat er mal gesagt, das ist eine seiner Grundideen, dass er das eben möchte, dass man deshalb so viel oder fast ausschließlich auf Prinzipien setzt im Offensivspiel und nicht auf feste Besetzung, dass er eben möchte, dass da viel, dass das noch schwerer ausrechenbar ist. Und dann setzt er eben auf spielstarke Spieler. Marcel Hardl ist, glaube ich, momentan der beste Spieler der zweiten Liga. Da hast du eben, hast du schon gesagt, Elias Hard, wahnsinnig stark im 1 gegen 1. Eine richtige Entdeckung, der auch früher oder später in der Bundesliga spielen wird, glaube ich. Und da hast du jetzt mit Eggestein und auch mit Zoller, mit so einem spielintegenten Spieler wie Zoller, der hat ja damals, muss man ja auch ehrlich sagen, der VfL Bochum ist ja auch dank Zoller oder fast hauptsächlich dank Zoller aufgestiegen. Das war der zentrale Punkt da vorne drin, der eben total intelligent sich da immer bewegt hat, obwohl er körperlich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt die absolute Maschine ist. Das heißt, er wird da schon total gut reinpassen in das Spiel. Ich sehe jetzt momentan nicht, wie man das Johannes Eggestein verklickern soll, nachdem er drei solche Spiele abgeliefert hat. Und dann auf einmal sagt er, ja du, jetzt der Simon, der weiß ich auch nicht, der ist zu uns gewechselt gerade, da muss man den jetzt mal ausprobieren oder so. Das wird eine Schwierigkeit, aber es ist momentan, wahrscheinlich werde ich am Samstag gegen Nürnberg bei dem Spiel komplett an die Wand fahren mit dieser ganzen Euphorie. Das ist für mich auch okay. Ich finde, euphorische Phasen darf man durchaus haben, finde ich, und muss auch so sein, gerade wenn es dann so gut läuft. Und gerade diese spielerische Komponente, die reinkommen. Wir sind jetzt der FC St. Pauli in seinem 13. Zweitliga-Jahr. Ich habe so viel Scheißfußball gesehen, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Ich freue mich einfach darüber, dass der FC St. Pauli jetzt eines der Teams ist. Es gibt mehrere Teams. Nürnberg jetzt am Wochenende, die sind auch so. Die haben auch eine klare Idee im Ballbesitz. Magdeburg ist total toll, das schaue ich wirklich gerne. Und dann gibt es ja noch so etwas wie Walter Ball und so, die auch da viel versuchen. Also in der zweiten Liga passiert schon relativ viel wieder. Also da ist wieder mehr Mut gefragt. Und St. Pauli ist da mit dem Hürzeler Fußball. Das ist schon sehr besonders. Also das ist tatsächlich spielerisch. Haben die da schon echt ein echtes Funt hingelegt, auf das andere Trainer einfach keine Lösung haben? Ich kann mir auch keine vorstellen. Also muss ich auch dazu sagen, ich habe schon mal überlegt. Ich habe Fabian Hürzeler auch schon mal gefragt, wie würdest du eigentlich gegen die spielen? Und er hat gesagt, ja, weiß ich nicht. Wir haben auf alles eine Lösung. Also wenn die Gegner mannorientiert spielen, das war letzte Saison in der Rückrunde, war das immer eine Option, die die gegnerischen Teams gewählt haben. Da hatten sie Probleme, aber das haben sie jetzt gelöst. Also da haben sie Lösungen angeboten gegen Schalke. Da hat er so mannorientiert gespielt, da haben sie das eigentlich ganz gut gelöst. Schalke hat das auch überhaupt nicht gut gemacht, muss man dazu sagen. Aber da hat Marcel Hartel, mit Marcel Hartel haben sie tolle Lösungen gefunden. Und dann mannorientiert heißt halt auch, eins gegen eins auf den Außenbahn gegen Elias Saad und Dapo Afoulaian. Das ist halt auch ein Problem, wenn du die Leute da erst mal hinkriegst in die Position und dann eins gegen eins stehend. Das heißt also, wenn du da komplett mannorientiert gegen St. Pauli spielst, dafür ist St. Pauli zu stark in den direkten Offensiv-Duellen. Nur raumdeckend ist aber auch ein Problem, weil dann gibst du denen eben da den Raum rein und nur aufs Zentrum ist halt auch inzwischen ein Problem. Also St. Pauli hat momentan für alles in der Offensive, für alle gegnerischen Mittel, sie zu stören, haben sie Lösung und bieten sie Lösung an und das schaffen sie auch, auf dem Platz während des Spiels das so umzustellen, also das anzuwenden und das mit einer Sicherheit, die ich beeindruckend finde. Ich bin jetzt seit 36 Jahren alt, verfolge den Fußballer, der St. Pauli sagen wir mal, seit 25 Jahren äußerst intensiv. Da waren schon tolle Teams dabei, aber ob wir spielerisch schon mal so stark waren, das weiß ich nicht.
Jetzt war mal nur noch ein Wort dafür. Hürzeball finde ich irgendwie nicht gut.
Oh ja, bloß nicht. Hürzeler Ball, bloß nicht. Irgendwas wird über kurz oder lang so etwas geben. Ich möchte mal eine These wagen, weil Fabian Hürzel ja auch beim FC Bayern ausgebildet wurde und weil er auch immer sagt, er selbst hat das Bayern-Gen und da ja auch aufgewachsen ist. Du weißt, welche These folgt, aber das bricht sich natürlich alles auf diesen Trainer runter. Und wenn es darum geht, wer ist denn der Star in der Mannschaft oder ist die Mannschaft der Star oder das System der Star, natürlich, Fabian Hürzel, die Quote, die der hat, ist unfassbar und es wäre unfassbar, wenn da nicht sogar Top-Teams auf sowas achten.
Ja, das würde voraussetzen, dass die Bayern 2. Liga gucken und ehrlich gesagt nach allem, was man so über den FC Bayern weiß. Aber das ist was anderes, aber was auf jeden Fall jetzt die Hörerinnen und Hörer verstanden haben, ist, warum diese 90 Minuten gegen Holstein Kiel, auch wenn es 0-0 geworden wäre, sehr interessant gewesen wäre. Denn wir haben auch schon wieder grandios überzogen. Es war ein Überziehen mit Ansage. Tim, ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du uns in aller Kürze, die irgendwie möglich war, erklärt hast, warum es gerade so viel Spaß macht, den FC St. Pauli zu gucken. Und das kann ich wirklich als neutraler Beobachtender bestätigen. Es ist einfach schöner Fußball. Und das gibt es nicht überall im deutschen Fußball. Danke dir, Tim, für deine Zeit. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke natürlich auch an Anna und Jörg, die ihr ja schon vorhin gehört habt. Und das war unsere Ligatur zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wie immer der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. Ihr da draußen, ihr macht all das möglich. Ich habe jetzt für den September 1600 Euro an Honoraren überwiesen. Und die kamen alle komplett von euch. Also vielen Dank dafür, aber keep it coming, bitte. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr wie. Bis bald, macht's gut, bleibt gesund.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funksäule.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.